crois qu'un certain nombre d'entre nous
ont des trains déchets pas quoi donc on
va commencer je remercie madame la
ministre de sa présence madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous
accueillons donc aujourd'hui madame
agnès pas venir une hache et ministre
chargé de l'énergie pour nous entretenir
avec elle sur le projet doit pouvoir
d'achat ça c'est de l'ultra court terme
et bien sûr au delà sur la politique
énergétique du gouvernement face à la
grave crise que nous traversons
l'énergie bien sûr au centre de nos
préoccupations mais aussi de celle de
tous les français à l'échelon européen
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
souvent ici la sortie légitime et
nécessaire d hydrocarbures et
spécifiquement des hydrocarbures russes
en l'espèce fait entrer l'europe dans
l'équivalent d'un nouveau choc pétrolier
j'ai malheureusement l'âge de me
souvenir de ce premier choc pétrolier
j'ai la conviction que cette situation
peut être une opportunité pour accélérer
la transition énergétique et pour
définir enfin une politique énergétique
structure est stable réaliste et pérenne
qui permettent les investissements et
leur amortissement à l'échelon national
la production nucléaire du groupe edf
s'établit entre 280 et 300
térawattheures pour l'année 2022 et
c'est un minimum historique
cette situation n'est pas seulement
imputables au phénomène de corrosion
sous contrainte mais il est également
imputable à l'absence de cap et
l'absence d'investissements en matière
de nucléaire 2014 en inscrivant dans la
loi la limitation à 50 % de notre
électricité d'origine nucléaire le
gouvernement a fait croire aux français
que nous aurions besoin de moins de
nucléaire
et en est il a donc inscrit dans la
foulée la fermeture de centrales or le
doublement des besoins en électricité
par l'électrification des usages et la
décarbonation avec la sobriété
énergétique nécessaire avec le
développement souhaitable des énergies
renouvelables implique une augmentation
des volumes d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire c'est une faute politique
lourde qu'il nous faut maintenant
corrigé il aura fallu attendre le
discours pré électorale de belfort
quelques semaines avant la fin du
quinquennat pour que l'exécutif engage
la mort ce d'un changement
nous estimons ici à la suite de nos
travaux que c'est un peu tard madame la
ministre mais finalement pas à la
hauteur non plus des besoins s'agissant
du prix de l'électricité il l'a dit
place et 3000 euros par mégawatt heure
le 4 avril 2022 cette fois cité c'est un
maximum jamais atteint les ménages des
entreprises les collectivités sont
durement affectés et ce n'est pas le mot
la moindre des choses la situation du
groupe edf et en plus extrêmement tendu
le goût le groupe pardonnez-moi est en
grève et d'une dette de 43 milliards
ayant perdu 10 milliards en raison du
relèvement du plafond de la reine et 20
milliards en raison du phénomène de
corrosion sous contrainte dans ce
contexte critique je souhaiterais donc
vous poser plusieurs questions notre
d'années notre collègue daniel grémillet
président du groupe d'études énergie
rapporteur du projet de loi ce pouvoir
d'achat pour notre commission vous
interrogeons également nous avons besoin
de savoir madame la ministre ce que
recouvre la renationalisation annoncée
du groupe edf nous ne voyons pas bien
encore en quoi elle permet de répondre
au mur d'investissements du groupe qui
doit financer 60 milliards pour le grand
carénage et 60 milliards minimum pour
les nouveaux repères dont flamanville ne
voyons pas non plus si l et r le
contentieux sur les concessions
hydroélectriques que nous avons
notamment avec l'europe pouvez vous donc
j'allais dire nous éclairer ce n'est
peut-être pas le meilleur mot surtout je
veux le dire très calmement mais aussi
très solennellement la nationalisation
d'edf en 1946 son changement statutaire
en 2005 tout cela nous l'avions autorisé
par la loi il n'est donc pas admissible
que sa renationalisation savoir réduite
à une opération financière ou
réglementaires il faut légiférer sur
l'avenir d'un opérateur est essentielle
à la vie de la nation votre prédécesseur
s'y était engagé si même au sénat le 13
janvier évoque 2021 est ce que madame la
ministre vous vous y est engagée à votre
tour le gouvernement doit tenir parole
mais même en l'absence de majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale les
institutions fonctionnent et nous sommes
bien entendu en capacité d'examiner un
tel texte je vous dis que nous ne
satisferont pas d'un débat de deux
heures sous forme de questions réponses
en second lieu nous avons besoin de
savoir comment se prépare la rue du
nucléaire notre commission a adopté un
rapport complet trans partisan
préconisant de réaliser à minima le
scénario n 03 de rte pour ce faire il
faut construire au moins 14 p r nous
savons qu'il faudra peut-être faire plus
rte nous l'a dit roy c'est une trois de
plus si nous ne pouvons pas prolonger
les réacteurs existants delà de 60 ans 9
si la consommation d'électricité
augmente plus fortement
compte tenu de la réindustrialisation
que nous appelons tous de nos voeux du
pays notre commission préconise
d'inscrire cette trajectoire de
construction dans la loi quinquennale
sur l'énergie qui sera présenté en 2023
et de l'assortir d'un plan de
financement elles suggèrent aussi
d'étudier ces réacteurs supplémentaires
d'ici la loi pour donner aux
législateurs tous les éléments
nécessaires à sa décision quelle est
votre position sur ses propositions ni
répondez-vous favorablement en dernier
lieu nous avons besoin de savoir comment
se prépare l'hiver prochain et les
suivants lors de notre table ronde tenue
au sénat le 13 juillet dernier no 3
énergéticiens angie total énergie et edf
nous ont appelés à nous préparer un
hiver sans gaz russe d'ailleurs on voit
dans les derniers jours ce qui en elle
cette situation de tension extrême sur
le plan de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement notre commission a
été probablement la première à s'en
inquiéter dans un rapport sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement le 24
février dernier nous avions alors
formulé 12 préconisations auquel aucune
suite pour le moment n'a été donnée vous
engagez vous à les instruire au delà de
ces instructions de ses parts dans au
delà de ces recommandations
comment le gouvernement se prépare-t-il
à cette perspective beaucoup de mesures
liées à l'énergie du projet du projet de
loi sur le pouvoir d'achat sont
structurels où sont les dispositions
pour soutenir edf pour relever la
production nucléaire développer les
énergies renouvelables soutenir le
biogaz les biocarburants et comment
garantir l'acceptabilité sociale du plan
de sobriété énergétique que vous
annoncez car pour certains ménages
certaines entreprises ou certaines
collectivités la transition énergétique
est encore trop coûteuse voilà je passe
la parole à notre rapporteur daniel
grémillet
un présidente madame amis chers
collègues tout d'abord je souhaiterais
échanger avec vous sur le projet de loi
pouvoir d'achat dont je suis rapporteur
sur le volet énergie
sur la forme je ne peux faire l'impasse
sur les délais ce projet de loi madame
la ministre nous l'examinerons dans des
conditions acrobatiques le texte a été
présenté en conseil des ministres et des
ministres 7 juillet le parlement
l'examinent quinze jours plus tard le
texte a été adopté par l'assemblée
nationale le 21 juillet notre commission
l'a adoptée trois jours plus tard c'est
du jamais vu
la moitié des articles l'énergie ont été
adoptés en séance publique à l'assemblée
nationale est dire qu on nous avait
annoncé une nouvelle méthode
censée revaloriser le rôle du parlement
favoriser la co construction en amont
par ailleurs de très nombreuses
dispositions ne sont pas évaluer
l'impact l'étude d'impact et minimaliste
je n'ai pu obtenir dans les travaux
préparatoires que le coût chiffré des
stocks de gaz rien sur le rsa rien et je
vous dis simplement c'est vraiment
inadmissible la situation à laquelle
nous travaillons sur le fond je voudrais
vous entendre sur plusieurs points
s'agissant de la reine nous sommes
arrivés en commission un point
d'équilibré avec le relèvement à 49,5
euros de son montant à et l'abaissement
à 120 térawattheures de son plafond
appuyez-vous cette position nous avons
aussi à appliquer directement dans la
loi l'annualité du guichet de la reine
demandée par tous les professionnels et
la commission de régulation de l'énergie
soutenez-vous cette position concernant
la validation législative du contentieux
de la reine elle éteint les seuils
contentieux les seuls comptes en ne
pensant contentieux afférents aux
consultations laissant à changer la
question de l'articulation avec le cadre
constitutionnel et européens
craignez-vous une annulation du décret
de mars et si oui quel en serait le coût
pour l'état enfin pour ce qui est des
pouvoirs de crise nous avons essayé et
continuons de trouver un équilibre en
situation d'urgence énergétique d'une
part et la liberté d'entreprendre et le
droit
deux propriétés d'autre part vous
obligez vous a budgété toutes les
mesures de soutien y compris les
indemnisations des ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative et au plus tard
la loi de finances pour 2023
ensuite je voudrais échanger le goût sur
la crise énergétique actuelle
la commission européenne est dorénavant
favorable à une réforme du marché de
l'énergie le gouvernement plaide-t-il
pour la suppression du principe du coût
marginal car on en a entendu tout et son
contraire sur le sujet et que pense-t-il
des contrats d'approvisionnement à long
terme quelle que soit la source
d'énergie utilisée
qu'ils soient demandées par les
prophètes qui aide qui sont demandées
par les professionnels le bouclier
tarifaire arrivera à expiration
dès la fin de l'année les tarifs
réglementés de vente des crises et ne
couvre que 28 % de la consommation et
ceux du gaz 7%
envisagez-vous d'élargir les tarifs
réglementés de vente pour expliciter
pour les entreprises et collectivités
non éligible et entendez-vous surseoir
l'extinction des tarifs réglementés de
gaz qui arrive au 1er janvier 2023
c'est possible dans le cadre de la
réforme annoncée du marché de l'est
n'est de l'énergie enfin je souhaiterais
vous interroger sur la relance du
nucléaire la présidente a indiqué que
nous avons publié un rapport très
complet sur le sujet avec mes collègues
jean pierre moga et jean jacques michau
nous appelons à régler rapidement
plusieurs problèmes ceux du groupe edf
avec le phénomène de corrosion sous
contrainte ceux du groupe hors anneaux
lié à ces usines à l'ags pour les
déchets à marcoule pour le mox quelle
est l'action du gouvernement en ce sens
nous appelons aussi à accélérer la
construction des réacteurs car la
fenêtre de tir pour parvenir en disposer
d'ici 2030 2050 et droite étroite quelle
est l'intention du gouvernement sur ce
sujet enfin nous plaidons pour instituer
un modèle robuste du financement à
l'échelon européen on démonte en des
mondes
des films dé financement par fonds
propres par achat direct par près par
prix garantis avez vous un modèle
préférentiels et qui doit être la place
de l'état selon la cour des comptes
cette place est indispensable aux côtés
du def voilà madame un ministre mes
chers collègues des questions
merci daniel je vous propose madame la
ministre de répondre à cette première
salve de questions un peu large
d'ailleurs et ensuite je donnerai la
question aux deux co-rapporteurs du
rapport nucléaire jean jacques michau
jean pierre moga et l'ensemble de mes
collègues très nombreux qui viennent de
s'inscrire voilà donc je demande à tous
une sobriété
efficace
merci beaucoup madame
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur je vais me
permettre d'introduire mon propos pour
poser le débat et chemin faisant essayer
de répondre à toutes vos questions
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vous remercie de l'organisation de cette
audition puisqu'elle me donne l'occasion
de poser les priorités de mon ministère
en matière de politique énergie climat
parce que c'est son périmètre et de
parler des mesures énergétiques
d'urgence prévues dans le projet de loi
sur le pouvoir d'achat je commencerai
par quelques éléments de contexte que
vous connaissez mais qui paraissent
quand même utile de rappeler l'enjeu
c'est de faire preuve dans cette période
de beaucoup d'agilité de réactivité tout
en préparant les grandes transformations
qui permettront à notre pays d'atteindre
la neutralité carbone en 2050 le sixième
rapport d'évaluation du giec
vous le savez ils nous alertent une
nouvelle fois sur la nécessité de
prendre des actions rapides et à grande
échelle pour limiter le réchauffement à
2 degrés les scénarios qui prévoit de
limiter le réchauffement à un degré 5
implique que les émissions mondiales de
gaz à effet de serre atteignent un pic
au plus tard en 2025
2025 c'est pas demain c'est aujourd'hui
nous constatons déjà les effets de ce
dérèglement climatique au travers
d'épisodes de canicules successifs d'
incendies à répétition d'assèchement de
la nappe phréatique de fonte de nos gars
glacier de montée du niveau des océans
ou encore de la disparition d'une partie
de la biodiversité et ces phénomènes
nous le savons sont la conséquence de
l'activité humaine dans le même temps la
guerre en ukraine et ses conséquences
géopolitiques ont bouleversé les
circuits d'approvisionnement de produits
énergétiques fossiles pétrolier de gaz
naturel rappelant la dépendance de notre
économie nos modes de vie aux énergies
fossiles importées les français en
subissent directement les conséquences
puisque l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie représentent 60% de
l'inflation qu'elle nous faisons face
depuis le début de l'année en dépit je
le souligne du blocage des prix parce
qu'il s'agit bien d'un blocage des prix
du gaz et de l'électricité pour les
ménages et des mesures carburant que
nous avons mises en place face à cette
situation nous agissons les mesures du
projet de loi pouvoir d'achat que vous
avez examiné lundi dans votre commission
donne à l'état les leviers d'action pour
sécuriser nos approvisionnements de
l'énergie cet hiver notre responsabilité
c'est nous préparer au scénario et pire
car il existe ce scénario c'est une
interruption totale des livraisons de
gaz russe aujourd'hui vous l'avez
compris il y a petits jeux politiques de
la part de nos amis russes qui
descendent les fournitures mais qu'il ne
les coupe pas sur le notamment le tuyau
nord stream 1 donc nous sommes
aujourd'hui à 20% de la capacité de
livraison du tuyau de nord stream 1 les
mesures de ce projet de loi vous les
connaissez c'est la faculté de
réquisitionner les centrales à gaz qui
produisent l'électricité en cas de forte
tension sur notre réseau et nous
permettent de mieux les réguler il
s'agit à la fois de protéger le système
gazier et protéger le système électrique
vous avez compris qu'il est fortement
interconnectés le paradoxe de la france
c'est finalement d'être plus exposés à
un risque sur les lectrices c'est que
d'être exposé sur les risques sur le gaz
puisque nous importons beaucoup de gaz
nous sommes un point d'entrée pour les
livraisons européennes en revanche nous
souffrons ponctuellement d'une situation
où vous l'avez dit notre productible
d'électricité est tendanciellement en
baisse j'y reviendrai sans doute dans
les questions l'assemblée nationale a
encadré la cogénération de ce dispositif
pour protéger les usagers je pense que
c'est pas tout à fait légitime deuxième
mesure le projet de terminal méthanier
flottant du havre qui est nécessaire
pour remplacer rapidement le gaz russe
est un projet qui concerne la saison
2023 2024
mais je me permets de souligner que
cette saison ne sera pas simple puisque
si les livraisons de gaz sont
interrompues d'ici la fin d'année ça
voudra dire que nous aurons une année
complète sans gaz russe l'hiver suivant
peut-être même plus dur que l'hiver
précédent je tiens sur ce point a
souligné que nous n'augmentons pas notre
consommation de gaz donc d'émissions de
carbone nous remplaçons simplement un
fournisseur de gaz par d'autres nous
sorte nous ne bougeons pas sur notre
trajectoire de réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre c'est un point
qui me paraît important et par ailleurs
ce projet a été conçu évidemment avec
des évaluations environnementales
mais c'est le délai et l'organisation de
ces heures de ces évaluations sur lequel
nous faisons des accélérations de
processus enfin nous souhaitons
sécuriser le rehaussement du plafond de
la reine de 21 à voiteur réalisée en
urgence cette année cette mesure a
permis de limiter la hausse des primes
énergie des entreprises et des
collectivités territoriales qui n'ont
pas accès aux tarifs régulés je note
d'ailleurs que vous m'interrogez sur
comment faire en sorte que plus
d'acteurs est accès aux tarifs régulés
la réponse vous la connaissez il faut
avoir plus d'accès à la reine en tout
cas c'est comme ça que sont construits
aujourd'hui notre système sans à rennes
l'augmentation des prix l'électricité
aurait été de 20% pour les résidentiels
et les petits professionnels qui ne sont
pas aux tarifs régulés
25% pour les entreprises et les
collectivités qui ont plus de 10
salariés 25 % et 40 à 60% pour les
industriels électro intensifs avec un
fils risque financier réel pour ces
derniers on parle de 150 entreprises et
de 45 mille emplois en jeu
si cet article n'était pas voté le
risque il n'est pas un risque financier
c'est un risque sur les entreprises qui
ont bénéficié du tarif de la reine
puisque l'effet serait un rattrapage
rétroactive des prix d'électricité sur
les factures des entreprises et des
collectivités locales c'est un effet
mécanique direct irréversible je tiens à
préciser ce point vous m'interrogez sur
le niveau de plafond de 120
térawattheures je les ai précisé à
l'assemblée nationale 120 térawattheures
compte tenu du productible anticipe la
nucléaire l'année prochaine c'est un
plafond raisonnables pour les années
24-25 puisque comme vous le savez la
reine a vocation à s'éteindre enfin 2025
c'est un plafond qui aurait vocation à
augmenter puisque notre objectif est
d'augmenter la production nucléaire donc
au fond de la proposition que on
pourrait vous faire ou sur lequel on
pourrait vous inviter à réfléchir c'est
d'avoir un plafond qu'ils soient mobiles
en fonction de la réalité de la
production d'énergie nucléaire et qui
permettent de protéger au fond une
partie de
2,7 de ce plafond est de le destiner à
ceux de nos acteurs économiques qui en
ont besoin aujourd'hui et c'est ce que
c'est ce que vous mettez dans votre
question s'agissant de l'annualité du
guichet je dois vous dire ma surprise
parce que c'est plutôt le contraire qui
est demandé par les professionnels les
professionnels ils sont dans la tente
d'avoir une rapidité d'intervention et
une agilité et s'il n'y avait pas eu
cette possibilité d'intervenir en infra
annuel il y aurait pas eu ce guichet en
2021 22 pardon si nous sommes en 2022 et
nous aurait adoré subissent les
augmentations de coûts donc je ne peux
pas me joindre pour le coup soutenir
cette annualité du guichet qui n'est pas
non plus d'ailleurs demandé par la
creuse pour être très clair
enfin je crois que sur la reine j'ai
répondu à tous je regarde et oui il ya
une question qui est qui est en creux
qui est sur le devenir de la reine alors
ça pour le coup je pense que tout le
monde s'accorde à dire autour de cette
table que c'est pas un système qui est
satisfaisant c'est un système face de
satisfaisant pour edf c'est un système
satisfaisant pour les
pour les consommateurs pas totalement
satisfaisant mais c'est aujourd'hui
celui dont on dispose pour protéger les
consommateurs donc vous savez qu'il ya
eu une mission qui a été demandé à
philippe darmayan pour faire des
propositions sur ce qui pourrait être un
mécanisme futur darren vous savez
également que il ya eu des complètement
complément qui ont été
réalisés par des missions d'inspection
qu'on a aujourd'hui quatre schémas
possibles 1 qui paraît être le plus
praticable qui est une sorte de
tarification enfin de
d'un de taxes négative et positive qui
permet de rendre la structure de coûts
de ce rapport et pudique un de rendre la
structure de coûts en tout cas de
protéger les consommateurs en repartant
de la structure de coût réel du
nucléaire ce qui est sûr c'est que nous
partageons avec vous l'ambition que le
tarif de la reine soit fixé sur la
réalité des coûts complets de la
production d'énergie nucléaire d'edf et
qu'en tout état de cause lorsqu'il a été
fixé à 42 euros il ya un certain nombre
d'années ça paraîtrait pas illogique
qu'ils évoluent à fortiori dans un
contexte de forte inflation c'est pour
ça qu'il a été nous avons demandé à
relever sur les 21 watts heure
supplémentaire à 46 euros vin et c'est
pour ça qu'un certain nombre de corps de
contrôle ont pu se positionner sur des
prix qui tourne autour de 49,50 et je
crois reconnaître ce prêt dans le texte
et les amendements qui ont été portées à
l'assemblée nationale et en commission
c'est un c'est un tarif qui doit être
négocié avec la commission européenne et
je salue l'évolution de la commission
des affaires économiques d u la
subtilité de mettre le mandat de
négociation dans la loi c'est à dire à
la fois de dire ce qu'est la tante de la
représentation nationale mais de mettre
le codicille qui permet d'aller mener la
négociation et d'éviter d'avoir à une
sanction directe de la commission qui
dirait vous imposer un tarif sans nous
en avoir parlé non c'est pas ok et vous
pourrez remettre en cause tout le tout
le système
s'agissant
poursuivre mon propos sur
la suite de notre politique énergétique
vous le savez les petits pas ne
suffiront pas pour nous engager dans la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
nous devons engager des grandes
transformations
immédiate et radicale
ma mission c'est de faire en sorte que
la france soit le premier grand pays du
monde à sortir des énergies fossiles
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone et
je suis convaincu que nous sommes
aujourd'hui collectivement responsables
toucheront collectivement responsables
de la solution que nous devons trouver
notre devoir c'est d'agir pour léguer
une planète vivable aux générations
futures la stratégie que nous mettons en
place avec la première ministre repose
sur trois piliers qui ont été d'ailleurs
formulé avant même la guerre en ukraine
pense que c'est important de s'en
rappeler ces trois piliers ce sont la
sobriété l'efficacité énergétique je
rappelle que dans le scénario que vous
mentionnez il y à un effort considérable
de réduction des consommations
énergétiques à la réduction à usage
constant
et je distingue bien sobriété efficacité
sobriété c'est un changement de
comportement efficacité c'est un
changement technologie qui nous permet
d'utiliser des technologies qui sont
moins consommatrices d'énergie en gros
vous passez d'une voiture carburant en
voiture électrique ou vous changez deux
chaudières
l'accélération massive du déploiement
des énergies renouvelables c'est le
deuxième élément il est
extraordinairement important le
troisième élément c'est la relance de
notre filière d'excellence au clair
c'est pour ça que résultant en mix
énergétique vous mentionnez le foie de
besoin d'électricité mais avec 50%
d'énergie nucléaire vous êtes en
augmentation de production d'énergie
nucléaire pas si je suis claire 70% de
sens aujourd'hui c'est plus petit que
50% de 200 demain et donc c'est bien ça
l'équation alors je n'ai pas encore fait
la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie et ça sera un exercice où il
nous faudra collectivement bouclé mais
pour moi la résultante de l' équilibre
entre énergies renouvelables et
l'énergie nucléaire est d'ailleurs il
faut surtout pas oublier la chaleur
parce qu'on a tendance à être très
focalisée l'électricité c'est l'arrêt du
résultat de ce qu'il est possible de
faire en termes physiques et en termes
ensuite d'acceptabilité sociale et de
temps des projets donc ce n'est pas de
l'idéologie c'est la remise à plat de
tous les scénarios des choix entre
différents scénarios et les chiffres à
la fin de la programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie la sobriété et d'efficacité
nous avons lancé un plan sobriété qui
est porté par le président de la
république et la première ministre
depuis un mois plusieurs groupes de
travail avec un objectif établir une
feuille de route pour faire la première
marche la première marche est une
réduction de 10% nous nous donnons
2024 comme échéance pour y parvenir
pourquoi parce que cette première marche
avec censée être la plus facile à faire
les 30% qui resteront seront
probablement plus difficilement
atteignable
le plan que nous construisons et repose
avant tout sur l'action des acteurs et
des gros acteurs l'état les
administrations les ministères doivent
être exemplaires et engager des actions
en ce sens dans les bâtiments publics et
dans la gestion de leurs agents les
entreprises doivent être exemplaires et
surtout ils ont les moyens de le faire
ils gèrent des centaines de milliers de
salariés il gère des millions de mètres
carrés et c'est celle viella qui sont
les plus efficaces se rappelle que ça
porte à peu près 75 % de notre
consommation donc certes on peut faire
des petits gestes à la maison mais
l'essentiel va être trouvée par cette
mécanique collective et structuré
d'action des grands acteurs et c'est
très exactement ce que nous faisons ce
que nous faisons aussi dans les
établissements qui reçoivent du public
les commerces la grande distribution en
particulier les centres commerciaux et
dans le logement que nous avons lancé
groupe de travail aujourd'hui que nous
ferons avec les collectivités locales en
essayant de rassembler toutes les bonnes
pratiques mises en avant par les
collectivités locales et de leur mettre
à disposition l'ensemble de l' expertise
des opérateurs et des administrations de
l'état pour les aider à aller chercher
les endroits où il ya le plus de grain à
moudre en termes de consommation
d'énergie ça sera bon pour leur bilan
carbone ce sera bon aussi pour leurs
finances et je pense qu elles n'y seront
pas
insensible dans le cadre de ce je veux
saluer d'ailleurs au passage les
résultats très rapides des groupes de
travail sur les grandes surfaces
commerciales parce que en deux semaines
ils ont sorti beaucoup de mesures qui
sont assez importantes qui vont chercher
au delà des températures de consignes
mais sur la ventilation des éclairages
le refroidissement il faut penser que
l'impact sur leur compte de résultat il
n'aurait pas non plus totalement
insensible dans le cadre de ce plan de
sobriété ce qui est clair c'est que je
ne dérogerai pas à un principe je ne
demanderai jamais aux français qui sont
dans une situation de sobriété
contraintes de précarité énergétique de
faire des efforts je pense qu'il faut
l'avoir en tête nous avons 12 millions
de français selon certaines associations
qui sont en situation de précarité
énergétique et nous avons donc un double
mouvement à faire d'un côté accompagner
ces français là pour les sortir de cette
dépendance aux énergies fossiles pour
lequel ils n'ont pas les moyens
naturellement de de s'en sortir et c'est
pour ça que les boucliers se justifie et
de l'autre côté faire en sorte que ceux
qui ont plus d'aisance et des capacités
à bouger puisse changer de pas évoluer
dans leur consommation d'énergie la
sobriété c'est aussi du bon sens et met
fin à des aberrations écologiques est
très consommatrice d'énergie savez que
j'ai annoncé que je prendrais 2 décrit
dans les prochains jours c'est pas des
décrets qui épuisent le sujet en est
très clair mais c'est juste d'envoyer
aussi des signaux et de simplifier les
choses le premier généraliser
l'interdiction des publicités lumineuses
quelle que soit la taille de la ville
entre 1h et 6h du matin le deuxième
interdit pour un magasin d'avoir ses
portes ouvertes alors que la
climatisation de chauffage fonctionne je
rappelle que ces 20% de consommation
d'énergie en plus en hiver je pense que
là aussi il ya des progrès à faire le
tout c'est que tout le monde joue le jeu
c'est à dire que c'est toute une rue est
fermée alors le consommateur poussera la
porte c'est toute une re c'est dans une
rue où vous avez un compte un commerçant
sur deux qui ferment pas sa porte je
comprends que ceux qui font l'effort
soit un petit peu affectée considère que
il faut se donner les moyens d'aller
alignés on va dire le collectif j'ai
également demandé aux énergéticiens
c'est très importante de s'engager en
proposant aux français des contrats
avantageux qui valorisent leur effort de
sobriété en leur permettant de faire
plus d'économies alors les grands
anciens qui ont vécu la crise de 70
j'étais tout jeune à l'époque
se souviennent des tarifs heures creuses
heures pleines tarifa pointe mobiles d'
mais on peut aujourd'hui avec les
nouveaux outils aller chercher un peu
plus loin vous avez des tarifs ejp aussi
qu'on peut sortir de deux grandes
périodes l'enjeu c'est de mieux piloter
sa consommation et potentiellement de
mieux la piloter à distance notamment
avec les outils numériques
on a la chance en france d'être très
équipés en conteur poursuivra la
consommation électrique et bientôt en
conteur poursuivra la consommation de
gaz donc c'est un vrai levier est à la
portée des français
d'efficacité
énergétique vise à libérer les français
de leur dépendance aux fossiles c'est un
grand chantier pour rénover massivement
les bâtiments publics les logements les
changements de système de chauffage ou
encore pour renouveler notre parc
automobile je vais pas y revenir mais
dans le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif vous verrez que les budgets
alloués sur ma prime rénove et sur le
bonus écologique sont incrémenté de 400
millions d'euros chacun
cette année et que nous voulons avec
olivier klein faire en sorte de
retravailler de travailler tout
simplement sur la recherche d'un plus
grand impact encore de ces dispositifs
et j'ai aussi une responsabilité c'est
qu'il ya pas seulement le logement dans
la vie il faut décarbonés tous les
bâtiments donc ça sera un enjeu
important dans les prochaines années
nous devons développer dès aujourd'hui
massivement les énergies renouvelable en
particulier solaire éolienne mais ça ne
puisse pas le sujet il ya la géothermie
à l'hydroélectricité vous connaissez nos
objectifs production d'énergie solaire x
10 50 parc éolien en main en mer pour
atteindre 40 gigawatts d'ici 2050 et
derrière la volonté de développer les
dessous des filières industrielles sous
jacentes je pense qu'on est tous
conscients qu'aujourd'hui le
photovoltaïque c'est beaucoup de valeur
ajoutée asiatique que non en jeu c'est
plutôt de préférer la valeur ajoutée
française et européenne la france accuse
un retard dans le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables qui est massif ce
n'est pas faute de projet c'est pas
faute de projet c'est pas faute de
soutiens publics c'est en raison de la
lourdeur de nos procédures
administratives et contentieuses il faut
en moyenne 50 procédure pour construire
un parc solaire qui nécessite que
quelques mois de travaux plus de sept
ans pour un parc éolien terrestre plus
de 10 ans pour un parc éolien en mer ce
qui explique que la france possède
seulement un parc éolien en mer en
fonctionnement j'ai donc lancé un plan
énergies renouvelables il a trois
chapitres un chapitre organisations
comme en accompagner préfet comment on
densifie peut-être les services
d'instruction andré hade donc ça c'est à
notre main en tant qu'exécutif un
chapitre réglementaire nous avons
relancés notamment les projets qui
étaient bloqués en photovoltaïque en
éolien terrestre et en biogaz pour des
raisons de l'augmentation des prix de
ces projets et nous avons trouvé des
solutions qui ne coûte pas un euro
d'argent public et nous allons vous
présenter dans les semaines qui viennent
un projet d'accélération de la
transition énergétique sur lequel nous
avons démarré les concertations dans le
cadre de la nouvelle méthode fut même vu
pour un premier rendez vous assez rapide
je dois le reconnaître la cds des athées
et
la présidente de la cpd est et le
président de la commission président cdd
à tes affaires économiques on va y
arriver pour en parler et nous mènerons
une concertation de façon en parallèle
des concertations obligatoire et avant
la présentation au conseil des ministres
qui permettra de savoir à peu près où
sont les lignes rouges de chacun et les
envies de faire bouger le projet est
également
le président de la république a par
ailleurs fait un choix historique de
développer un parc nucléaire qui
concourent à notre indépendance
énergétique à l'alimentation des
émissions la limitation des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et à l'attractivité
de notre territoire par la compétitivité
la stabilité des prix de l'électricité
j'y reviens pas je pense que beaucoup
sur ces bancs porte une vision positive
du nucléaire vous m'avez posé un certain
nombre de questions la relance du
nucléaire c'est depuis 2001 je rappelle
que ces 470 millions d'euros dans le
plan de relance qui a permis de soutenir
la filière et de leur permettre de
monter en compétence c'est également un
contrat
stratégiques de filières qui travaille
sur les aspects compétences puisque
c'est un enjeu majeur
je rappelle également que nous sommes
effectivement calé sur un scénario qui
s'assimilent wayne 0,3 en fait il entre
deux scénarios de rte avec la
construction de 6 p r immédiatement
décidé plus les études a lancé sur 8 e p
r additionnel donc on retrouve les 14 e
p r le plan de financement je ne vous en
dirai pas beaucoup plus puisque il fait
l'objet nous sommes vraiment un stade
très préliminaire des travaux est
évidemment la renationalisation d'edf
c'est aussi une façon d'avoir une
souplesse dans les scénarios envisagés
en matière de financement avec la
volonté de rechercher un financement
public privé mais qui soit solide et
dans la durée
et sur le nucléaire vous m'avez
également poser une autre question que
je cherche comment ruiner les délais
la consultation en fait sur les deux
premiers réacteurs auraient vocation à
démarrer début octobre soit qu'elle peut
être deux semaines après la consultation
que nous lancerons sur la stratégie
française énergie climat donc grand
débat public c'est à une demande de la
cndp d'avoir un débat sur le mix
énergétique avant que de plonger sur les
débats particulier des centrales
nucléaires de palier je pense que c'est
une demande qui est légitime
sur
pense qu'on est à peu près au bout du
sujet l'opération de monter à 100% du
capital que nous menons sur edf c'est
une opération stratégique nous passons
de 84 % à 100 % c'est pour ça qu'il a
pas besoin de loi vous le savez
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas du registre du
législatif ç'aurait été nationalisation
il aurait fallu une boîte aurait été une
privatisation il aurait fallu et le mois
là nous montons en capital il nous
passant de 84 à 100% en revanche sur
l'hydroélectrique les le contentieux
effectif est effectivement l'objet d'une
discussion avec la commission européenne
il y à des scénarios qui se dessine on
n'a évoqué la possibilité par exemple de
mettre en place une quasi régie qui
serait probablement plus facile avec des
tensions à 100% du capital d'edf et en
tout état de cause là ce serait moi qui
irait au parlement donc il ya des
aspects autour d'edf qui sont de nature
législative il y en a d'autres qui sont
de nature
on va dire exécutive si ce n'est que
vous avez la trace de cette opération
dans le projet de loi de finances
rectificative pas complètement neutre
c'est une grosse trace de l'ordre de 10
milliards d'euros que vous avez dans le
compte d'affectation spéciale donc c'est
là aussi l'angle pour en parler vous
avez évoqué le terreau v du gaz et le
fait que
il est mis fin à la fin 2023 je rappelle
que c'est une décision de justice qui a
confirmé qu'il fallait supprimer ces
tarifs pardon s'est joint 2023
il n'est donc pas possible de les
recréer à ce jour néanmoins le terme et
ne protège en rien sur le gaz parce
qu'il doit refléter le prix de la
molécule et comme nous ne sommes pas
producteurs de gaz en france ce prix se
forment sur des marchés internationaux
nous n'avons pas la capacité à
l'influencé on peut faire des boucliers
saint-hervé on le fait déjà pour tous
les clients gaz et il faudra
effectivement
travailler je pense que c'est un travail
qui a vocation à être partagées assez
largement avec le parlement sur des
repères clairs sur les trajectoires de
prix des différentes énergies puisque
la nuit 2023 et suivantes vont se passer
dans des conditions de température et de
pression qui sont des conditions qu'on
n'a pas connues objectivement ces
cinquante dernières années et qui vont
avoir à la fois en termes de
compétitivité du pays et de pouvoir
d'achat des conséquences importantes
donc comme en règle et quels sont les
leviers à notre main c'est évidemment
une discussion importante à partager
voilà je crois que j'ai à peu près fait
le tour j'ai fait le tour jeu pour
revenir juste une minute sur l'arène
nous il nous semble que ça hein
un plafond darren à 130 5 térawattheures
pour 2024 et 2025 serait géré un
compromis raisonnable vous saviez que le
plafond était à 150 francs à pied deux
pilotes puisqu'on entend l'inquiétude
manifestée à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat mais je déposerai peut-être un
amendement en ce sens
voilà je vais très bien merci beaucoup
mais un ami je ne suis pas inquiète
parce que vous le nombre d'inscrits pour
vous poser des questions je pense que
les sujets sur lesquels chacun va
pouvoir réagir je vais donner la parole
à nos deux co rapporteurs du récent
rapport d'abord jean jacques michau et
ensuite jean pierre moga
madame la ministre dans notre rapport
sur le nucléaire l'un des enjeux
centraux et celui de la stratégie or
l'actuelle ppe prévoit toujours la
fermeture de deux réacteurs au-delà des
2 des 2 de la centrale de fessenheim
pourquoi ne pas la réviser dès à présent
ce serait un signal fort pour la filière
de plus l'un des enjeux centraux et de
celui de la formation c'est la leçon du
chantier de l'epr de flamanville nous
estimons qu'il faut moins de 30000
emplois pour construire les 6 p r c'est
ce que des f nous dit comment entendez
vous répondre à cette problématique
un autre enjeu et la recherche et le
développement
tous les opérateurs de recherche ont
indiqué le budget alloué n'est pas à la
hauteur entendez vous le relevez dans la
prochaine loi de finances enfin un autre
enseignement du rapport et de la
territorialisation des projets le
nucléaire est demandé dans certains
territoires nous préconisons un grand
appel à projets national pour permettre
aux collectivités volontaires de faire
valoir leur candidature pour les eps à
l'étude ou les smr les élus locaux que
nous avons rencontré de fessenheim
cadeaux comme d'autres sont intéressés
qu'en pensez vous merci beaucoup jean
jacques jean pierre moga
merci madame la présidente d'abord merci
madame la ministre de consacrer une
partie de votre temps précieux pour
cette audition comme vous le savez comme
l'a rappelé notre présidente notre
commission et force de proposition dans
le domaine de l'énergie qu'il s'agisse
l'année dernière de l'hydroélectricité
ou cette année du nucléaire et de
l'hydrogène bas carbone à ce sujet nous
avons récemment présenté avec mais mes
deux collègues dont daniel et grenier
jean jacques michau en rapport fromlet
dix propositions
celui-ci
replace le nucléaire au coeur de la
planification énergétique
nationale au delà du discours de belfort
quelle est votre ambition sur l'énergie
nucléaire et au delà des mots quels
seront vos actes je pense notamment
premièrement à la simplification des
procédures où vous l'avez évoqué pas
quelque chose de simple mais quelque
chose me semble-t-il vu le contexte
indispensable
deuxièmement aux modalités de
financement de cette relance bienvenue
de l'énergie qui va représenter
quelques milliards et vous avez parlé de
470 millions tout à l'heure pour la
relance ça sera bien plus que ça donc il
faudra nous nous expliquez nous faire un
certain nombre de propositions dans ce
domaine troisièmement au futur rôle mais
vous l'avez on peut évoquer aussi ddf
pour accompagner une telle ambition
nous insistons sur la nécessité d'un
notaire résilient aux nouveaux enjeux
climatiques et numérique et souhaitons
qu'ils aient des effets l'état s'engage
dans ce sens en étudiant au mieux la
localisation et la conception des
installations nouvelles et en appliquant
un plan d'action pour celles existantes
madame la ministre partagez vous cette
lignée et ce point de vue le nouveau
nucléaire ne serait être acceptée
socialement sans une gestion des
dossiers nous souhaitons que le
gouvernement
acte le devenir des installations de la
hague dès la prochaine loi quinquennale
sur l'énergie en êtes-vous d'accord et
le prévoyez-vous par ailleurs nous
n'opposons pas loin de là l'énergie
nucléaire les énergies renouvelables à
cet égard pouvez vous nous donner de la
visibilité quant au futur projet de loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables tant son calendrier
de même que son contenu font l'objet de
beaucoup d'émoi les altermoiements face
à l'urgence peut-on se permettre de
retarder l'examen de ce projet de loi
qui était je rappelle une des
propositions phare du président candidat
enfin qu'il s'agisse diderot et actis
tda grau d'agde rivolta isme de
méthanisation ou encore de nouveaux et
de petits nucléaire
le sénat vous fait un certain nombre de
propositions qui ne manquent pas et qui
pourrait nourrir utilement ce débat
essentiel je vous remercie
combien je vais prendre quatre premières
questions fabien gay a précisé m fabien
merci madame la présente bonjour madame
la ministre merci de vos propos
introductif qui nous donne beaucoup de
contenu je vais poser une question de
deux minutes parce qu'on aura deux jours
peut-être trois jours de débats qui vont
commencer demain mois une première
question sur le texte qui vient le même
c'est un texte sur le pouvoir d'achat
les cinq premiers articles à prendre le
débat on est d'accord on aime d accord c
du pouvoir d'achat daudet
aux ménages français moi je suis contre
le fait des primes je suis plutôt pour
le salaire mais on a le débat et puis
après à partir l'article 5 ou 6 on a
tout un tas de questions qui sont
évidemment très intéressante ce qui
m'intéresse beaucoup et on aura le débat
mais qui protège en rien pardonnez moi
le pouvoir d'achat des français si on
avait une question sur le pouvoir
d'achat on ne pouvait parler du chèque
énergie et du triplement du chèque
énergie proposé par l'ademe ce que nous
nous portons depuis longtemps mais
l'abaissement de la tva à 5,5 bon tout
un tas de mesures mais on ne les
retrouve pas et on a tout un tas de
questions extrêmement technique dont la
reine mais qui n'ont pas à mon avis à
mon sens qu'ils vont redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux français donc je suis assez
un peu surpris et je pense qu'il y avoir
un certain nombre d'amendements qui vont
être encore déclarée irrecevable
notamment sur ces questions je porte
après on en accord ou en désaccord donc
je suis un peu surpris sur cette partie
du texte et puis la deuxième
vous venez de le dire donc y aura pas de
débat sur la rue étatisation moi je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est pas une
nationalisation c'est une raie et attise
à sion d'edf donc loupé à d'ailleurs
lancé sur les marchés nous invite à ne
pas avoir de débat ni c'est au parlement
n'y avait les usages et encore moins
avec les salariés qui ont d'ailleurs
beaucoup lutté contre le plan et recule
et le plan grand edf et moi je crois
bout d'un moment donné où on peut pas
avoir le débat ici au parlement sur
l'arène de main et ne vaut avoir aucun
débat sur l'opérateur historique edf et
sa restructuration avec le parlement
franchement j'ai un petit problème je
vous le dis je peut-être pas le seul que
je sais qu'il ya eu des questions de
daniel grémillet et de franck montaugé
la semaine dernière à monsieur le
ministre bruno le maire et je parte
achats je pense que nous avons besoin
d'un débat politique sur l'avenir d'edf
sur la question du nucléaire et toutes
les questions qui vient d être posée et
pardonnez moi je veux pas être trop long
mais je pense qu'on ne soutient pas le
nucléaire depuis 2001 en tout cas je
pense qu'il ya eu plus d'atermoiements
que ça jeu mais après je peux avoir tort
sur l'arène moi je ne comprends pas je
vous dis que ça ça soutiennent les
ménages donc ça soutient les acteurs
alternatifs parce que ça fait 12 ans que
nous expliquent qu'ils vont investir
dans la production ils ont investi e
aucun euro est d'ailleurs en 2020
lorsque le prix le cours de l'énergie
s'est effondré en pleine pardonnez moi
madame la présidente devait s'effondrer
en plein de confinement est tombé à 21
euros se sont tous dits retirer de la
reine et c'est pas pour ça qu'ils ont
baissé la facture des usagers de
l'électricité
donc voila et moi je pense que ça et je
peu après être battu dans le débat mais
je pense que au minimum nous devrions
avoir un grand débat politique la
ministre au chili s'y était engagé vous
y revenez je trouve ça plus que dommage
il fabien pardon de vous demander de des
considérants coursières on
va se régaler sylvie à noël ensuite
patrick chauvet merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre vous savez
combien la rénovation énergétique est un
enjeu au majeur il est au legs l'allumé
est un enjeu majeur en termes de
sobriété et d'efficacité énergétique
pourtant au 1er juillet 2022 une partie
de l'aide accordée par l'anah aux
propriétaires occupants modestes voire
très modeste pour la rénovation
énergétique de leur logement devraient
disparaître la suppression de cette
prime intervient dans un contexte
particulièrement difficile pour ces
ménages frappe l'est frappés de plein
fouet par l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie l'inflation au moment où le
gouvernement avait décidé de supprimer
la prime sérénité l'escomptait que
celles ci puissent être remplacés dans
le plan de financement des travaux des
ménages par les certificats d'économie
d'énergie
ainsi les subventions de l'anah au titre
de ma prime grenoble serait devenu
compatible avec la mobilisation décès
sur les mêmes travaux ce qui était
impossible jusqu'à lors or les marchés
des ses états est actuellement très
volatile avec des cours s'orientant à la
baisse depuis ces derniers mois en effet
d'un côté pour les travaux d'isolation
aidé par la prime le niveau des c est
actuellement inférieure aux mômes au
montant de la prime sérénité ce qui aura
pour conséquence que les projets seront
moins bien aidés et en outre les
montants estimés d'essai avant le
démarrage des travaux sont général n'a
généralement valable que si moi ce qui
s'avère insuffisante dans le cadre de
projets impliquant plusieurs postes de
dépenses faute de moyens pour
subventionner au bon niveau les travaux
de nombreux projets seront revus à la
baisse voire abandonner ce qui est
dommage en termes de transition
énergétique ce je souhaitais donc savoir
ce que vous comptiez entreprendre pour
remédier à cette situation et je profite
également de mon intervention pour vous
sensibiliser sur la technicité extrêmes
de ces démarches dead qui se révèle
particulièrement périlleuse pour les
citoyens très technique est lourde et
qu'il aura les amène très souvent à ne
même pas pouvoir bénéficier de ces aides
au final je remercie merci à sylviane
patrick chauvet ensuite anne catherine
loisier
s'arrêtera pour ce premier merci madame
la présidente merci mal nos ministes de
votre présence je vais très rapide parce
que la question a été posée par notre
présidente il s'agit du contentieux
européen sur les concessions du groupe
edf vous vous rappelez que le 28 frais
vieux février dernier par la loi sur
l'aménagement du rhône nous avons trouvé
une solution à la cua la cnr la
compagnie nationale du rhône n'est qu'à
l'époque le débat pour odf est arrivé
dans les échanges au moment de cette
voie là et qu'on n'avait pas de réponse
très précise donc il y avait toujours
trois hypothèses l'ouverture à la
concurrence le regroupement par vale ou
ce que vous avez évoquées dans votre
réponse la quasi raji pardon mais je
suis un peu surpris que depuis février
nous n'ayons pas avancé du tout sur
cette question là qui reste
assez pesant pour edf même s'il ya une
évolution celle que vous avez décidé
pour edf ou voilà c'est une question qui
a été posée mais la réponse me paraît
toujours la même c'est à dire que nous
n'avons pas une réponse à cette question
merci patrick anne catherine loisier
merci madame à présent pas nos ministres
alors que tout devrait revenir sur une
une énergie dont on parle peu et
d'ailleurs qui n'avait pas évoqué ce qui
sort souvent des radars des pouvoirs
publics c'est le beau l'énergie bois
qui aujourd'hui est dans une situation
conjoncturelle un peu particulière
puisque de nombreux dans un cadre de la
démarche décarbonation d'un certain
nombre d'industriels on voit fleurir de
nombreux projets qui inquiète et je
voulais attirer votre attention sur le
fait que les scieries les industriels de
la filière doivent absolument être
prioritaires pour l'accès à cette
énergie cet hiver car en fait si elles
sont contraintes dans leur production
des ciels doivent baisser leurs
activités cela impactera forcément le
volume 2 / nécessaire pour les pellets
et on sait combien aujourd'hui un nombre
important et grandissant de français se
chauffent grâce à cette source et puis
attiré aussi votre attention sur les
projets qu'ils grandissent en est de
plus en plus nombreux qui utilise la
biomasse
là aussi ce phénomène risque de
déstabiliser en fait les les filières de
valorisation des bois à longue durée
notamment les panneaux thiais donc voilà
je pense que ces différents points
devront faire l'objet d'arbitrages
public dans le cadre du portage des
dossiers et puis une question vous avez
parlé des nerfs du déploiement des umr
électrique est ce que vous pourriez nous
donner quelques éléments sur la
production de ses nerfs en france ces
derniers mois puisque lors de récents
rapports on nous a souligné que en
allemagne par exemple il y avait une
diminution de 50 % de la production
issue des nerfs électrique ces derniers
mois donc quelle est la fiabilité à long
terme de ces deux sources d'énergie
merci pose la question évidemment de
l'intermittence madame la ministre vous
voulez bien peut-être faire une coupure
pour répondre
merci beaucoup alors
s'agissant de la fermeture des réacteurs
donc ça c'est un sujet qui sera abordé
dans le cadre de la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie je rappelle
une chose c'est que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une période d'examen et
prolongation de nos centrales nucléaires
de 40 50 ans c'est un des éléments qui
explique d'ailleurs les maintenances
très lourdes qui sont faites sur les
réacteurs vous savez qu'aujourd'hui 30
réacteurs sur 56 sont arrêtés douze pour
des raisons de corrosion que l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire
a indiqué ce matin qu'elle trouvait que
le projet enfin le plan de reprise et de
traitement de ces traits de ces
problèmes de corrosion du paris s'est
approprié et qu'elle ne demandait pas d'
arrêt complémentaire de centrales ça
c'est un point qui montre la qualité du
travail je crois qui a été mené par edf
et donc les autres centrales qui sont
aujourd'hui arrêter les 18 autres le
sont pour des raisons de maintenance
alors ça va du chargement du réacteur
sujet assez classique tous les 12 ou 16
mois suivant le modèle de réacteur a
effectivement les visites triennal et
les visites décennales et lorsque vous
êtes au bout des quarante ans c'est un
processus très lourd il faut avoir en
tête que rien ne dit que on ira enfin
que toutes les centrales passeront le
cut enfin la prolongation de 50 à 60 ans
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que rien ne dit que des
centrales passeront de la nouvelle
visite de 60 ans et ce qui a changé dans
le paysage ces dernières années mais
vous l'avez évidemment en tête c'est en
fait le retour d'expérience de fukushima
qui a monté de manière assez sensible il
a fallu le travail et donc ça pas été
fait de manière immédiate mais qu'à
monter de manière assez sensible tout le
travail de visite décennale et de
prolongation des centrales c'est à la
fois une bonne nouvelle veut dire que on
monte le niveau de sécurité mais ça veut
dire aussi que
la lourdeur de ces visites est un
élément dimensionnant de notre parc
nucléaire donc c'est pour ça qu'il est
là aussi important de ne pas partir sur
l'idée que tout est extensible j'ai
entendu mais les américains ont prolongé
jusqu'à 80 ans
on en reparlera ce qu'on se rapproche de
l'objectif
mais en tout état de cause ça ne peut
pas être un scénario central jusque je
veux partager
sur la question de la formation c'est un
point absolument crucial je pense que
c'est quasiment le challenge le plus
important edf nous dit que son projet
juste sur le nouveau nucléaire je parle
pas donc des ingénieurs qu'il faut quand
même mettre à disposition pour faire
toute la partie courante faire tourner
les centrales organiser les visites
classiques et c'est plus tous les
ingénieurs qu'il faut mettre sur les
grandes visites et les prolongations de
centrales et là vous devez en rajouter
tout un paquet pour faire le nouveau
nucléaire c'est 10 % de nos capacités de
formation d'ingénieurs en france 10%
à un moment où le nucléaire a pas aussi
bonne presse auprès des jeunes que dans
cette salle pour le dire comme ça
et donc il ya un vrai travail de
alors c'est un travail qui n'est pas
totalement étranger parce qu'on l'avait
sur la partie industrie mais il ya un
vrai travail
d'explication de comment cette
technologie est absolument au coeur de
la transition énergétique et de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
pourquoi c'est extraordinairement
moderne de s'engager dans ces carrières
et passionnant pourquoi la france a
toujours même si certaines de ses
compétences ont écorné un avantage
compétitif à la matière en la matière et
est donc c'est un sujet majeur ça voudra
dire aussi qu'il faudra aussi regarder
sur d'autres compétences de gestion de
projets complexes et qu'il faudra
regarder peut-être sur des profils qui
ont géré des projets complexes à
l'étranger mais c'est un sujet majeur
probablement le plus dur et je vous
rejoins complètement sur la r&d nous
avons un milliard d'euros qui est
engagée dans france 2030 en plus du
reste sur le nucléaire à la fois pour
accompagner des projets de smr mais
également sur les questions par exemple
de combustible le cycle du combustible
et moi je souhaiterais dit très
rapidement que l'asn puisse aussi en
bénéficier il irait scène sur tout ce
qui est comment être une autorité
4.0 5.0 puisque là aussi on peut
imaginer qu'avec de l'analyse de data
avec de l'intelligence artificielle
ça pourrait être une façon de gagner du
temps et on sait que ces processus sont
très lourd donc de mettre l'intelligence
là on en a besoin et de faire gagner du
temps sur des process d'analysé plus
classique donc voilà oui il ya un
milliard d'euros aujourd'hui dans le
france 2030 sur la territorialisation
des projets nous avons fait le choix et
edf a fait le choix pour le moment de
privilégier les sites sur lequel il ya
déjà des centrales nucléaires ce sont
des sites ou en règle générale ya une
très grande acceptabilité sociale le la
centrale nucléaire est un poumon
économique
c'est également 50 ans de retour
d'expérience donc les populations sont
très au clair elles sont plutôt plus au
fait des enjeux et donc les deux
premiers réacteurs sont positionnés sur
penly les deux suivants sur gravelines
les deux suivants il ya à balance de
sites sur le rhône avec une analyse
avantages inconvénients de ces deux
sites et ce qui est assez important
c'est qu'on a de la réserve foncière sur
les sites existants ce qui est très
précieux
j'entends néanmoins l'appel à projets
c'est peut-être pas pour la semaine
prochaine voilà c'est pour le partager
mais ça m'amène à une autre question
c'est que je pense que sur les énergies
renouvelables
la question de la territorialisation et
de la planification et clés et qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on arrive à passer dans
ce set dimension je sais qu'il ya des
départements par exemple dans les
hautes-alpes qui font des cartes au la
préfète a pris sur elle de faire des
cartographie des zones où au foot c'est
pas la peine d'aller même des énergies
renouvelables parce que si on empile des
difficultés on n'y arrive pas des zones
qui sont plus propices qu'elle et soumet
à la concertation de ses élus locaux et
ça permet d'apaiser très fortement le
dialogue avec les élus locaux qu'il
s'agisse d'une niveau régional ou du
niveau départemental ou agglomérations
et communique c'est probablement une
bonne approche et ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qu'on voudrait cultivés sur la
simplification des procédures et il vous
est toujours sur langue du nucléaire
n'oubliez pas qu'un nucléaire c'est même
en mettant très très vite et en étant
extraordinairement efficace des énergies
qui délivreront en 2037 1,12 je vous
invite collectivement à penser à ce
qu'on fera entre 2022 et 2037 en termes
de production d'électricité et c'est là
que je reviendrai avec les énergies
renouvelables peu importe oui nous avons
des besoins d'un véhicule législatif
assez assez restreint il ya une petite
dizaine de mesures
pour pour faciliter
le ne pas ralentir les projets donc
c'est quelque chose qui peut être évoqué
les acteurs edf et de la filière sont
très comment dire soutenant de cette
démarche et appelle à notre action
rapide c'est pas une action de la
semaine prochaine mais c'est une action
des prochains mois clairement
sur
l'organisation de l'état par rapport à
la gestion du programme nouveau
nucléaire nous avons décidé de créer une
délégation
interministérielle nouveau nucléaire qui
aura 4 mission une mission en direction
du tout ce qui est organisation des
procédures notamment pour accompagner
ces procédures et faire en sorte qu'elle
ça se passe mieux possible plus
rapidement possible une mission autour
de la dérégulation de marché et des
questions on va dire plus générale 2,2
de la contrainte du projet tel qu'il est
positionné une mission autour des
compétences comment s'assurer qu'on
anticipe les compétences à la fois cols
blancs et cols bleus puisque vous avez
aussi énormément de compétences
électrotechnique soudure j'ai enfin je
rentre pas dans la chaudronnerie qui
vont être indispensables et qui sont pas
des compétences sortie d'école sont des
compétences avec une grosse expérience
intérieure
est également sur l'enjeu de la filière
et de la sous-traitance puisque là aussi
c'est un enjeu très important
sur le futur rôle d'edf dans ce set dans
ce programme et bien je crois qu'on a
une équipe hérouard qui a vocation à se
mettre en place et à
porter ou accompagner ses projets ça
sera un des sujets en tête des deux
listes du futur du futur dirigeant d'edf
dont vous savez que le recrutement est
lancée la localisation de sites je les
ai évoqué l'installation de la hague oui
il faut avoir une donner une visibilité
sur cette installation je sais pas si le
lieu et l'heure celle après la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
mais clairement si vous prenez un
rétroplanning les projets de nouveaux
nucléaire vous arriver très vite au
sujet de stockage de déchets au sujet de
traitement de déchets et comme c'est
assez implacable comme
industrie puisque vous avez des délais
d'anticipation très lent en gros si on
s'en préoccupe pas dans six mois on
risque de rater là aussi
le jalon temporel beaucoup il va falloir
s'en occuper sur la loi accélération de
la transition énergétique
nous sommes dans une dernière ligne
droite schukin réunion encore maintenant
complètement les conclusions mais nous
voulions l'articuler autour de quatre
enjeux le premier enjeu c'est comment
rendre plus désirable ses installations
avec la problématique du partage de la
valeur
auxquelles vous serez sensible en tant
que voix des collectivités locales
potentiellement mais également partage
de la valeur en direction du client
final les consommateurs des habitants
deuxième enjeu il est autour de
l'accélération des procédures le
troisième enjeu c'est la libération de
foncier qui pourraient être utilisés je
prends souvent l'exemple de foncier
routier délaissé c'est typiquement le
genre de sujet où on peut sans trop de
dommages avant c est le quatrième en jeu
et elle est au tour de la planification
et notamment on peut penser sur le
photovoltaïque marin moi vraiment
je veux sortir du débat les éoliennes
terrestres c'est pas bien je pense que
je regarde c'est pas triste du pas de
calais qui a une forte pression
d'éoliennes sur son territoire on sait
que la répartition des éoliennes sur le
territoire français est assez inégal
c'est quand même lié aussi à des
conditions de température et de pression
qui sont extérieurs mais pas que mais
pas que et donc il ya un vrai enjeu a
peut-être essayé de se dire enfin
d'aller vers une logique où moi je serai
président de région je considérerais
qu'être autonome d'un point de vue
énergétique
c'est un enjeu majeur de compétitivité
de mon territoire et donc après comment
on fait et comment on déroule sa et
est-ce que c'est du photovoltaïque est
ce que c'est des réolais est-ce que
c'est du rétrofit d'éoliennes c'est à
dire j'ai déjà des éoliennes j'ai pas
envie d'avoir plus de territoire avec
des éoliennes mais je peux
éventuellement les
comment dire les améliorer et gagner 25
30% voilà c'est ça qu'il faut mettre et
à la fin faut voir si sa boucle parce
que la vraie question c'est à la fin est
ce que ça boucle c'est à dire est ce
qu'on a vraiment le potentiel de
production qui correspond à la volonté
de réindustrialisation en particulier
des territoires qui aujourd'hui ont
beaucoup d aullène il ya quand même une
correspondance industrie électrique
n'est pas négligeable sur
tac tac tac méthanisation joue on a
débloqué des projets là aussi et c'était
évidemment un sujet sur lequel on est à
l'écouté c'est d'autant pour nez
d'autant plus aller coûte que le
problème du gaz russe fait que le biogaz
est très désirable il ya un vrai sujet
c'est que mal géré souvent ces projets
sont présentés comme clé en main
des agriculteurs qui n'ont pas le temps
qu'ils n'ont pas forcément la formation
pour
les maintenir comme il faudrait et on
observe des fuites de méthane et vous
savez comment être le méthane est un gaz
qui est très fin qui contribuent au
réchauffement climatique de manière très
intense alors qui disparaît aussi assez
vite sur un temps de vie humaine mais
bon c'est pas c'est pas fantastique donc
il ya probablement les moyens de réussir
en fait c'est comme ça je pense qu'il
faut raisonner c'est comment se donner
les moyens de les réussir
il ya beaucoup aussi de deux recours
contre ces projets c'est pour ça que
en lien avec la première ministre
propose ont déposé un décret au conseil
d'état qui permet d'encadrer c'est
d'ailleurs une de vos propositions de
mémoire dans un des rapports je pense
que c'est celui de monsieur besson qui
dit on encadre les contentieux sur les
projets de d'énergies renouvelables
dis-moi faut passer soit le juge rend sa
décision soit on passe automatiquement à
l'étagé au dessus sur les trois
juridictions et ça permet au moins
d'avoir un délai prévisible du
contentieux monsieur guay alors quel
rapport entre les mesures énergie je
vous parle de ce que je connais je
parlerai pas de la location etc elle est
mesure où
leur renonciation à des contrats les
mesures énergie et pouvoir d'achat en
fait plus on se prémunit contre des
ruptures d'approvisionnement en énergie
moins on a de chances de tendre le
marché et d'augmenter les prix c'est
assez simple c'est ça la logique sous
jacente
pourquoi aucun débat sur des f
parce que en fait c'est avoue enfin je
veux dire dans les prérogatives
évidemment des assemblées vous avez
toute latitude et je suis d'ailleurs
devant vous pour répondre à des
questions y compris sur edf dans ce qui
relève de mon portefeuille c'est à dire
pas la partie actionnariale qui piloté
par bruno le maire mais je suis
évidemment votre disposition et
j'imagine que ministre de l'économie
aussi sur ce débat mais s'il n'y a pas
de support législatif ya pas de support
législatif pour cette décision de monter
au capital en revanche je n'ai dit il ya
des sujets qui nécessite de passer par
la loi la reine on en a parlé à
l'instant quoique pas toujours et
surtout les la partie hydroélectrique
pareil ce sont des sujets législatif est
ce que la reine soutien des acteurs
alternatifs je vous répondrai simplement
sur l'augmentation d'un térawattheures
c'est clair que non c'est à dire qu'il
ya un contrôle très serré de la creuse
pour que le l'effort qui est fait des f
soit directement passer aux
consommateurs et nous nous avons
de manière assez serré moi j'avais réuni
avec jean françois carenco avant le
remaniement il y a des aironi de
l'histoire l'ensemble des acteurs de
énergétique et des filières
industrielles à la fois pour dire très
clairement aux énergéticiens que si on
les prenait la main dans le pot de
confiture y aurait des conséquences et
des sanctions administratives et d'autre
de l'autre côté pour dire aux acteurs
industriels que s'il constaté que les
prix n'étaient pas ajustés à due
concurrence de ce qu'ils devaient être
et c'est une formule mathématique donc
c'est assez automatiques alors il
fallait qu'il nous remonte la formation
qui saisissent la creuse donc le système
était clairement précisé j'entends ce
que vous dites sur le long terme c'est à
dire que le pari qui a été fait de dire
on va ouvrir le marché est pas demain il
va avoir des acteurs qui vont arriver
qu'ils vont investir et qui vont faire
des propositions alternatives s'est pas
exactement passé comme cela il faut en
tirer les conséquences c'est sans doute
retour d'expérience affaire à la
commission européenne
madame noël il n'y a pas eu de
suppression du dispositif sérénité je
veux vous rassurer sur sa et sur les c2e
gelé annoncé il ya quelques jours
nous avons
pris une
une mesure pour faire en sorte pas pour
soutenir le marché d'essai 2e j'ai
d'ailleurs également lancé ce qui
répondra à votre deuxième question sur
la démarche les démarches d'être très
compliqué c'est sûr que pour des ménages
précaires c'est pas le truc le plus
simple qu'on ait mis au point
nous avons déployé sur le terrain le
réseau anna et les réseaux face on a à
peu près 4000 ou 5000 conseillers qui
sont là pour accompagner le français
dans leur démarche c'est le premier
niveau et je lance un appel à projet qui
est financé par l'essai de ce qui
correspond grosso modo à 150 millions
d'euros d'efforts en direction des
associations qui accompagnent les
personnes précaires pour justement les
aider à préparer leur dossier à sortir
de la précarité vous savez ces démarches
fournissent associations type abbé
pierre pour monter les dossiers aller
chercher les financements conseiller sur
le choix des gestes à faire et faire en
sorte que tout soit bouclé
en appui de la famille en situation de
précarité énergétique
sur l'hydroélectricité monsieur chauve
et je prends le point alors rien à part
rien fait parce qu'il ya tout un travail
qui a été mené pour avec la commission
européenne
je les ai indiqué il fallait d'abord
cadré edf globalement c'est la montée au
capital et le 100% capital et à ça
permet de réfléchir plus sereinement
scénarios de sortie j'ai mentionné par
exemple le scénario de la quasi régie
pourrait être envisagée deux autres
propositions
c'est un sujet sur lequel je pense
qu'assez prochainement sera en capacité
d'éclairer les débats on est bien
conscient qu'on a besoin de donner de la
visibilité aux acteurs qu'il s'agisse de
la série n'est roudet ou d'edf ou qu'ils
puissent réinvestir puisqu'on à 6
milliards d'euros d'un de tête de
réinvestissement avec à la clé des
augmentations de capacité saas et de
l'augmentation de capacité qu'on peut
aller chercher alors c'est pas immédiats
malheureusement il faut trois quatre
cinq six ans mais c'est quand même de
bonnes augmentations de capacité madame
l'oise et sur l'accès au bois pour pour
les séries les scieries
moi je je partage avec vous mon
inquiétude sur l'accès aux peulhs et le
fait qu'il y ait beaucoup d'exportation
de pelé déjà
le fait que
nous nous voyons est également le prix
augmenter alors je veux préciser que le
chèque énergie permet bien de couvrir
aussi les peler pas ce qu'on me dit
c'est pas juste ciel violet pâle
l'épauler dans le chèque énergie en tout
cas il ya bien le peuple est en revanche
il sait c'est que cet emprunt sur lequel
j'ai interrogé mais mon administration
pour qu'on anticipe des problèmes de
tensions d'approvisionnement sur le
peuple et je n'ai pas de réponse toute
faite à date mais je c'est un point sur
lequel nous avons été alertés et puis
vous savez que les assises du bois en
février 2022 avec un certain nombre de
mesures qui visent à structurer
accompagner la filière
sûr
la biomasse est
je prends votre point d'attention c'est
effectivement aussi un point qui
remontait
voilà vous savez que la commission
européenne dans son
règlement lulucf
technique fait un système de cascades
ingo en gros on les usages sont
progressifs et hiérarchisé et on fait
attention à ne pas directement utiliser
le bois pour des usages de biomasse
inversement il faut être attentif
puisque suivant les espèces de darbres
les usages on va dire à haute valeur
ajoutée sont pas de faim sont pas
forcément approprié il faut aller
directement sur le bio masse donc c'est
un point de vigilance que nous avons
dans la traduction dans les prix log
sur la production des énergies
renouvelables là moi je n'ai pas le
sentiment qu'on ait une chute 10e par
deux donc je regarde non c'est un
oui j'ai bien entendu je n'ai pas j'ai
pas ce retour équivalent mais mais je
dirais creuse est papa pour la france je
suis à peu près sûr que on a une
stabilité de notre production s'est
offert une stabilité même une
augmentation et je rappelle quand même
que les énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui ses 20 milliards d'euros de
plus dans notre budget ça vous aura pas
échappé par rapport au modèle que
certains continuent à colporter en
disant ça coûte très cher aux français
etc aujourd'hui ces 20 milliards d'euros
de plus sur notre budget le solaire est
en progression en termes de production
l'éolien est stable par contre ça
m'intrigue ce que vous me dites sur
l'allemagne à bien comprendre le
pourquoi
si je peux me permettre je crois que
l'éolien et le photovoltaïque sont plus
important pourcentage de nerfs en
allemagne qu'en france ou en france
c'est principalement de l'hydraulique
notre énergie renouvelable à mon avis
voilà mais le solaire est en progression
dans l'absolu et l'éolien est
instabilité dans l'absolu ce qui
correspond au projet content et très
bien nouvelle salve de questions nous
allons commencer par amel gacquerre plus
pire kuipers
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je souhaiterais évoqué le sujet
des sources d'énergie locales et en
particulier l'exploitation du gaz de
vous le savez nous possédons dans notre
sous-sol d'importantes réserves de mines
inexploité cent dix mille kilomètres il
s'accumule dans les anciennes galeries
des mines de charbon et se relâche dans
l'atmosphère et ce qui est dommageable
c'est qu'il est un puissant gaz à effet
de serre 88 fois de plus que le co2
de plus ils représentent aussi donc un
vrai danger en matière enfin en matière
en d'explosion un danger d'explosion que
seule exploitation peut réguler en
france un acteur aujourd'hui
l'exploitent avec succès et cap donc le
gaz de mise sur plusieurs sites dans le
nord pas de calais comme vous le savez
et le convertit en électricité dans
notre contexte compliqué en matière
d'approvisionnement en hydrocarbures
l'exploitation de ce gaz peut être est
une ressource énergétique locale
précieuse et bien moins cher pour les
usagers vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
pour nos entreprises nos industriels
aujourd'hui très en demande je le redis
il est exploité aujourd'hui avec succès
en fait cela fait ses preuves
aujourd'hui en tout cas sur sur notre
territoire par contre aujourd'hui nous
connaissons des obstacles administratifs
et réglementaires qui l'empêchent qui
empêche pardon le développement de cette
source d'énergie locale des demandes
d'autorisation d'ouverture de travaux
miniers sont en attente de décision
depuis 2018 sans raisons connues
il n'y avait pas d' à part pourquoi
parce qu'il n'a pas d'impact que
n'aurait pas d'impact sur le site
puisque les forages sont existants et
une convention de mise à disposition
temporaire existent pour l'exploitant le
projet de loi sur la protection du
pouvoir d'achat prévoit le recours à des
énergies fossiles notamment avec la
réouverture de centrales à charbon mais
le gouvernement ne se positionne pas sur
l'exploitation du gaz de mine
donc ma position et ma position pardon
ma question est simple quelle est votre
position sur le sujet pourquoi nous
n'allons nous pas vers le développement
de cette source d'énergie locale qui je
le redis encore une fois et serait
précieux dans notre contexte
d'approvisionnement tendu merci beaucoup
à melle questions nouvelles twitter
merci huit chaises merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre je vous
laisse sur la méthanisation coll il a
évoqué peut-être un peu trop brièvement
le plan de la commission européenne pour
sortir des hydrocarbures russes mais
l'accent bien évidemment sur le biogaz
en france 1200 projets sont encore en
attente
entendez vous les débloquer et dans
quelles conditions et comment et de plus
la commission d'ailleurs envisage depuis
le 20 juillet une réduction de 15% de la
consommation de gaz de votre point de
vue est ce réaliste et comment pensez
vous y parvenir vous avez évoqué dans
votre propos tout à l'heure qui avaient
des recours qui avaient des incidents
qui avaient des accidents bon très bien
il y en a eu bien à vue il a été réglé
et on a apporté des solutions notamment
avec mon collègue ici
sur mon 1 seulement nous avons construit
ici au sénat un rapport qui a été adopté
à l'unanimité
et je vous conseille de vous y un de
vous instruire ce rapport dit il est
intitulé sur les missions d'information
donc la métallisation et ces
controverses et là nous apportons
soixante et une préconisation soixante
et une réponse proposition qui vous
permettent de répondre très rapidement
mais très rapidement au fait que nous
puissions développer et en simplifiant
les réseaux administrés tiff pour
pouvoir mettre en place cette
indépendance énergétique dont nous avons
besoin pour compenser les gaz russe
merci cher pierre patrick chaize ensuite
florence blatrix compta merci madame la
présidente en m'excusant déjà de pas
attendre mais je l'écouterai avec
attention première question c'est de
savoir à quelle échéance on connaîtra le
troisième site p r étant entendu que
évidemment le département de l'ain est
tout à fait en attente
deuxième deuxième question est plutôt
d'ailleurs une
remarque
ça concerne les effets de bord lié au
bouclier de 4% en fait quand les
opérateurs donc
applique cette réduction enfin c'est
plutôt cette imitation à 4 % ils le font
de façon hétérogène le fond sur les
heures creuses des heures pleines et
l'abonnement de façon donc tout à fait
hétérogènes et il en ressort que dans
les cas concrets les heures creuses sont
largement plus augmenté nous lors de 8%
les heures pleines de leur domaine pour
cent et les abonnements de cons
diminution de presque 1% ce qui fait que
finalement un consommateur qui aurait
fait des efforts en consommant en heures
creuses et donc en organisant sur la
consommation donc jusqu alors et est
pénalisé par cet effet de boucliers et à
une augmentation qui peut dépasser les
10% est ce qu'il n'ya pas quelque chose
à faire pour faire en sorte que les bons
élèves ne soient pas punis merci
si beaucoup patrick florence betrix
comptait ensuite et vine renault
garabédian merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre département de la
suite
voilà donc notre département qui fait
partie de la région vendre on attaque et
première région productrice
d'hydroélectricité de france je
m'inquiète des conséquences du
réchauffement climatique sur cette
production en effet le rhône et ses
affluents connaissent une baisse
sensible de leur débit on est déjà
environ
30% est ce cela devrait s'amplifier dans
les années à venir est les glaciers bien
entendu
mettant moins d'eau chaque année donc ça
également des conséquences sur notre
capacité
avec le la problématique du
refroidissement des centrales nucléaires
d'ailleurs le la centrale du bugey fait
l'objet d'une dérogation
donc voilà ma question comment votre
administration vous-même nam nam
ministre évaluez vous cette évolution de
capacités de production qui s'amoindrit
et quelles sont les réponses que vous
envisagez pour faire face alors qu'il
faut augmenter rapidement et
considérablement la part des énergies
renouvelables
j'aurais également une deuxième question
sur l'arrêté du 6 octobre 2021 qui
interdisait le cumul entre tarifs
garantis
et
subventions notamment au centre albi
ville ajoie qui
[Musique]
accompagne les communes
dans l'installation de panneaux
photovoltaïques
il ya une vraie dynamique dans mon
département mais depuis
depuis cet arrêté il est vrai que les
les centrales villageoise qui se lancent
sont en difficulté donc à l'heure où le
prix de l'électricité a augmenté et à
l'heure où vous avez une vraie marge par
rapport au prix de rachat voilà
envisagez vous de donner de la souplesse
et de permettre ce cumul de subventions
qui est vraiment important pas à long
terme en tout cas les premières années
et enfin un dernier point augmenter
notre ex comptage
[Rires]
concernant les foyers logements
notamment des résidences de personnes
âgées qui sont gérées par les communes
et ce sont les communes qui perçoivent
qui règlent l'électricité elle ne
bénéficie pas du tarif réglementé donc
les factures d'électricité ont augmenté
de 2,5 environ est évidemment si elle
les répercute aux résidents qui ont des
revenus très modestes
c'est difficilement possible au regard
de leurs revenus et sinon ça ampute
leurs dépenses ces crs donc comment
finalement permettre aux collectivités
dans ce cas-là de bénéficier du bouclier
tarifaire je vous remercie beaucoup
florence evelyne renou garabédian merci
ma présidente madame la ministre lors
les l'un des décrets que vous avez
annoncé consiste à interdire l'ouverture
des portes des magasins lorsqu'il ya une
utilisation de la climatisation et du
chauffage
cela concerne donc les commerçants j'ai
deux questions à vous poser à ce sujet
la première
qui va réaliser comment va se faire le
contrôle dans les magasins et d'autre
part quid des mesures pour les
entreprises qui ne sont pas des
commerçants et qui eux font un usage
excessif com du monde le sait de
l'utilisation de la climatisation dans
les différents bureaux j'ai une autre
petite question à poser si vous devez
autoriser vous proposer de limiter à 10
mois les délais de contentieux en
matière de projets énergétiques et
environnementaux est ce que pouvaient
développer le mécanisme que vous avez
utilisé merci merci evelyne et pour
terminer cette salve christian redon
sarrazy
unis dans bien des cas s'avère
excessivement
les opérations de validation de
rénovation d'intervention existants
ainsi que les opérations de reconversion
de bâtir de 30 questions et à enjeu qui
fabrique
les utilise à présent
qu'elle soutient des dispositifs
existants déjà évoqué
pour amplifier l'opération est bien des
ambitions à mi
mars
merci beaucoup alors
sur le gaz de mire de mines un pardon
madame gacquerre
c'est un sujet sur lequel est
effectivement on a travaillé je crois
comprendre que michel dagbert dépose un
amendement 428 sur ce sujet là dans le
cadre du pei jl pouvoir d'achat donc en
fait c'est manifestement les grands
esprits se rencontrent
qui j'espère apportera des solutions
pour être très clair tout ce qui est
comment dire la sécurité vous l'avez dit
rapidement la sécurité oblige à faire en
sorte de
de gérer et d'aller prélever du gaz de
mine sur les installations cette partie
là elle doit être valorisée c'est très
clair c'est le premier point en revanche
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour d'aller faire une opération va dire
de récupération qui s'apparenterait à de
l'exploitation d'hydrocarbures
donc effectivement valoriser l'existant
sans problème et le fer avec le bon
enfin en utilisant pleinement ce
potentiel qui n'est pas encore
totalement utilisée mais ré ouvrir entre
y est mais les mines pour aller chercher
le gaz de mine ça c'est quelque chose
qui ne correspond pas à notre
trajectoire climatique et qui répond pas
dans les délais à la problématique qui
nous qui nous regardent sur le biogaz
j'ai donc gelé a annoncé un je vais
prendre dans les prochains jours deux
décrets pour débloquer ces projets c'est
décret il donne 18 mois supplémentaires
par rapport au délai initial qui avait
une date à peu couperet au 31 décembre
2022 dont 18 mois supplémentaires pour
être réalisés et ils indexent les tarifs
sur l'augmentation des coûts alors vous
savez il ya deux niveaux de projets les
petits et les plus gros donc c'est pas
la même
mécanique mais in fine et ça revient à
tenir compte tout simplement de
l'inflation des coûts qui ont un impact
et des équilibres économiques de ces
projets c'est un peu la même logique
pour le photovoltaïque et l'éolien il
n'y a pas un délai de réalisation des
projets mais on autorise ses projets à
produire de l'électricité et de le
vendre directement sur le marché dans un
délai maximum de dix-huit mois pour
couvrir les surcoûts
de construction des projets et ensuite
ils reviennent aux tarifs régulés qui
sont avantageux pour pour les français
les objectifs biogas sont atteints dans
la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle mais vous avez raison je pense
que on peut aller plus loin et notamment
utiliser les infrastructures dont nous
disposons sur les infrastructures
gazières c'est un atout autant les
utiliser à d'autres
d'autres énergies qui sont bas carbone
et j'ai bien noté je suis d'accord avec
vous il ya des fuites etc donc c'est
plus une question où on a un retour
d'expérience il faut faire en sorte de
faire des choses bien on sait faire les
choses bien il faut juste s'assurer que
les choses sont bien
ses pas et on peut le faire rapidement
monsieur alors réduction de la
consommation de 15 % dans l'union
européenne
c'est un objectif volontaires qui peut
se transformer en objectifs obligatoires
dans une situation de crise et c'est le
conseil européen qui prend la décision
par la commission européenne sur
sollicitation d'un certain nombre
d'états
nous avons effectivement discuté ce
texte a été adopté en cinq jours c'est
assez inédit dans l'histoire de l'union
européenne est en fait la logique c'est
de se dire que nous avons une situation
de solidarité réciproque à construire
c'est à dire que certains états sont
extraordinairement dépendant du gaz
d'autres sont plus de l'électricité
c'est notre cas et ça c'est le premier
élément est si des sites sont arrêtés
faute d'approvisionnement en énergie
c'est de nature à désorganiser nos
chaînes de production froid qu on a
connu ça au moment de la coved personne
n'a envie de recommencer ça c'est très
clair et on a vu l'impact économique que
cela pouvait avoir
ce que nous avons introduit dans le
texte c'est aussi de tenir compte de la
réalité de chaque état c'est à dire que
les états qui
des stocks stratégiques qui sont remplis
au delà de l'objectif
et les états qui sature leur
interconnexion comme c'est le cas de la
france sont en situation d'avoir une
moindre
d'avoir un moindre effort à faire de gaz
ce qui est logique puisque en fait ça ne
sert à rien d'aller
économiser des molécules de gaz qu'on ne
s'est pas livrée aux collègues donc aux
voisins donc l'engagement que nous
prenons ces de saturer nos
interconnexion de gaz ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui d'ailleurs est
d'ailleurs l'espagne nous livre du gaz
enfin les flux sont inversés aujourd'hui
avant nous livre le livre maintenant
c'est elle qui nous livre et nous
livrons la fin nous livrons via la
suisse l'allemagne alors que hier
c'était elle qui nous livre est donc et
nous livrons la belgique alors que
c'était la belgique qui nous le devons
donc on organise un flux de toutes les
façades maritimes qui accueille des
terminal méthanier vers l'est et chacun
doit saturer les interconnexions et
ensuite dans une période de crise on
baisse les consommations ont autant que
possible pour continuer à saturer ses
interconnexions mais on va pas au delà
de ce qu'on sait faire pour aider les
autres puisqu'on a plutôt intérêt à
protéger nos sites industriels parce que
je vous donne un exemple qui est le plus
simple si l'irlande arrête son industrie
ça va pas servir le propos des autres
puisque c'est une île il ne pourra pas
livrer et en revanche elle peut
désorganiser
elle peut désorganiser sa propre fin des
propres chaînes européennes en arrêtant
des sites il faut avoir en tête que sur
le marché électrique nous importons
aujourd'hui l'équivalent de cinq
centrales nucléaires et grâce notamment
aux allemands ne pouvons supporter notre
production d'électricité est évidemment
toute la beauté du sujet c'est que une
partie des centrales nucléaires une
partie des d'électricité qui est importé
depuis l'allemagne l'est à partir de gaz
tout ça est assez haute aux références
et donc notre sujet c'est la résilience
du système électrique et gaz européen
est ce que c'est possible - 15 %
certains états sont déjà à -11 %
d'économie case
dokoui c'est probablement possible ça
suppose des efforts importants et ça
suppose une organisation et c'est pour
ça que nous travaillons à un plan avec
différents niveaux la sobriété étant le
premier niveau la possibilité
d'organiser de l'interrupteur bilité ou
de l'effacement comme cela existe pour
l'électricité sauf que l'électricité
c'est beaucoup plus facile parce que les
installations sont beaucoup plus
flexible le gaz pour un certain nombre
d'installations vous devez monter
lentement en chaleur et vous devez
redescendre lentement chaleur sinon vous
avez un risque d'abîmer lui qui
travaille c'est à d'ailleurs un des
points que nous regardons donc voilà
nous avons un plan à plusieurs niveaux
qui permet progressivement de rentrer en
scénario de crise est de nous protéger
collectivement au niveau européen sur
les soixante et une préconisation et
bien je me plongerai mais il n'y a
aucune raison comme des études dit pas
je n'en doute pas madame monsieur chaize
qui n'est plus là sur le père de ça sera
moins appel à projets qu'une analyse des
avantages et des inconvénients des deux
centrales qui peuvent prétendre
accueillir 2
deux réacteurs supplémentaires certains
ont mentionné le régime du rhône ça fait
partie des éléments à regarder et elles
regardaient dans une dynamique de
réchauffement climatique puisqu'on parle
d'installation qui sortent dans 15 ans
au plus rapide et qui ont vocation à
vivre à les 60 ans donc on parle de 75
ans il faut bien regarder les scénarios
de sortie en termes de réchauffement
climatique et est d'origine d'eau sur et
puis à d'autres éléments qui sont prêts
en cause et edf sont pris en compte et
nous allons décider avec edf sur la base
d' approche assez rationnel sur les
effets de bord du bouclier il est très
clair que si des gens font des sobriété
énergétique et payer des factures plus
importante au tarif horaire heure creuse
heure pleine ou il faut faire quelque
chose et moi j'ai besoin d'avoir les
éléments très clairement pour les
partager avec les jeunes nrj this year
j'ai écrit à tous les énergéticiens pour
leur demander
très concrètement un d'être capable de
communiquer à leurs clients ce qui a été
le coût du bouclier depuis le début de
l'année parce que je pense qu'il faut
que tout le monde réalise quand on parle
de milliards ce sont des chiffres
abstraits quand on le rapporte à sa
propre consommation on prend la mesure
du sujet donc ça je pense que c'est
important la deuxième chose c'est
effectivement de faire un travail de
remise à plat des tarifs pour pouvoir
favoriser ceux de leurs clients qui font
de la sobriété énergétique faut que ce
soit gagnant pour les gens vous que le
fait de faire sa machine à laver la nuit
se traduise de manière sonnante et
trébuchante dans le portefeuille des
français je pense que ce sera une
motivation complémentaires pour
participer à cet effort
sur
tac tac tac la capacité qui s'amoindrit
sur l'hydraulique qu'un réchauffement
climatique ça fait partie des sujets
effectivement à prendre en compte j'ai
pas encore les données chiffrées mais
vous savez qu'on a
toutes une analyse qui est porté par mon
collègue christophe béchu sur
l'adaptation réchauffement climatique
les stratégies nationales bas carbone et
donc ce qu'il faut enfin les
implications du réchauffement climatique
et la façon dont nous devons changer
notre appréciation des performances d'un
certain nombre d'équipements et changer
la manière de construire ces équipements
il s'est pas forcément les centrales
nucléaires qui sont les plus
problématiques à ce titre
sur
l'interdiction du tarif garanti des
subventions pour le photovoltaïque pour
les centrales villageoise je comprends
que il va avoir très
bientôt une circulaire pour préciser les
conditions de cumul possible entre
subventions et des tarifs ont
contractualisé
puisque c'est manifestement pas un point
qu'il est très clair
sur les foyers-logements enfin on peut
effectivement multiplier les risques il
y avait une question au gouvernement sur
ce sujet là tout à l'heure vous avez
raison il ya un certain nombre d'acteurs
qui échappe aux tarifs réglementés je
vais remonter le point mon collègue
olivier klein madame reno garabédian sur
l'ouverture des portes de magasins de la
climatisation c'est donc des sanctions
administratives qui peuvent être
prononce prononcées notamment par les
maires en tout cas leur police
municipale ça peut être aussi par des
autorités administratives autres
voilà
le je pense que la notion qu'il faut
retenir sur ça
c'est que le sujet se pose en des termes
différents pour les entreprises et pour
les commerçants les commerçants on sait
où en tout cas les commerçants nous
disent d'expérience que des portes
ouvertes génère un chiffre d'affaires
supérieur
et donc si dans une rue tout le monde
ferme sa porte le code client va
nécessairement faire l'effort de pousser
la porte si dans une rue une seule
partie une partie des commerçants font
l'effort et les autres ne font pas
l'effort vous avez à un phénomène de
passager clandestin est donc l'enjeu
c'est de donner les moyens haha
tous ceux qui notamment aux associations
de commerçants de dire attention c'est
tout le monde joue pas le jeu il ya la
possibilité d'une sanction et moi je
dois reconnaître que ces derniers jours
il ya eu quand même un effort assez
certains des gros acteurs et sur les
grandes enseignes on sera implacable on
ira faire des contrôles parce que je
pense qu elle donne le la et qu'elles
ont la capacité à fermer leurs portes
très objectivement et de les fermer et
puis on a un certain nombre de maires
qui sont mobilisés ces dernières
semaines compris d arrêter ça leur donne
une assise juridique pour prononcer les
amendes et pour les prononcèrent à
niveau qui n'était pas initialement
envisagées par part c'est par ces mères
et on travaille avec les associations de
commerçants évidemment je vois que le
premier temps c'est un temps
d'explicitation de pédagogie dévoila
d'accompagnement puis après derrière
c'est de faire en sorte que quand les
commerçants nous appelle en disant moi
je veux bien jouer le jeu ça fait une
semaine que je ferme ma porte mes jeunes
collègues qui le fait pas on puisse a
effectivement dire c'est pas ok quoi
voilà c'est il faut intervenir pardon
sur l'histoire du contentieux comment ça
marche l'idée c'est que à partir du
moment où le contentieux est introduit
s'il n'est pas jugée au bout de 10 mois
le tribunal était saisi et ça monte au
niveau supérieur donc du tribunal
administratif faire la cour
administrative d'appel puis de la cour
administrative d'appel vers le conseil
d'état c'est une démarche qui est moins
extraordinaire que ce que nous avons
voté dans le cadre des lois asa pour le
feu pour l'éolien marin qui est d'aller
directement au conseil d'état et sa
minaj effectivement les droits de la
défense et la possibilité de passer les
étapes mais ça existe d'ailleurs en
urbanisme pour certains types de projet
tak monsieur redon sarrazy donc vous
me poser la question sur un certain type
de rénovation je vais pas pouvoir vous
répondre avec précision ce que je vous
propose pas ce que ça implique aussi mon
collègue olivier klein c'est qu'on en
discute avec nos conseillers
parlementaires et convergent globalement
le voilà les types de situations dont
vous estimer qu'elles doivent être mieux
accompagnés qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
pleinement prise en compte de manière
générale le nous on est en tout cas la
première ministre a clairement indiqué
que son objectif c'est à dire c'est un
objectif de performance
en termes de réduction de l'empreinte
carbone est qu au regard des moyens qui
sont déployés sur ma priverait nov elle
attend un niveau de performance
supérieur donc je pense que le point a
été bien pris par olivier klein et moi
même une salle où il travaillait
c'est bien madame la ministre dernière
celle de questions va commencer par
henri cabanel et ensuite jean claude
dissaux
merci madame la présidente merci madame
la ministre
madame la présidente d'un à vos propos
liminaire vous vous disiez que
le gouvernement avait fait une faute
politique de ne pas anticiper justement
cette volonté d'investissement dans le
nucléaire je n'irai pas jusque là par
contre je dirais que
notre photo politiques tous convenu et
pas seulement qu'au gouvernement
macron c'est de ne pas avoir cette
culture de la politique prospective et
de voir à moyen et long terme notamment
en termes d'énergie ça je pense qu'aulas
pas et que
ça nous fait
justement légiférer souvent dans la
précipitation et c'est pas quand même la
meilleure des solutions
madame la ministre vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure en répondant à une question
que effectivement sur nos cinquante six
réacteurs il y en avait 30 qui ne
fonctionnait pas
je comprends que
dames les douze que vous avez signalé
qu'ils ont honte
donc un soupçon de corrosion avéré ça ne
soit pas ça soit difficilement dissipe
abl par contre sur les 18 autres
c'était des maintenance programmée alors
bon je sais que vous allez évoqué la
période donc du coc vide qui a empêché
effectivement mais quand même
comment peut-on et là je me place à la
fois en tant que parlementaire parce que
je sais privilège de vous poser des
questions mais le citoyen lamda
de savoir que peut-être pour l'hiver
prochain on va lui couper l'électricité
et est de savoir que sur 56 réacteurs en
a trente qui ne sont pas en
fonctionnement
comment expliquez vous le fait que nous
n'ayons pas pu anticiper les maintenance
programmée des 18 réacteurs
merci henri jean claude tissot ensuite
rémy chardon
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre j'ai deux principales questions
la première sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique nationale et la deuxième sur
la gestion concrète d'un ancien site
d'extraction d'uranium tout d'abord les
autres je souhaitais revenir sur la
question d'approvisionnement en uranium
qui est régulièrement mis sous tapis par
les acteurs du secteur nucléaire il
s'agit pourtant d'un sujet d'une grande
importance pour notre souveraineté
énergétique
en effet on estime que pour faire
fonctionner 56 réacteurs nucléaires edf
a besoin de 8000 à 10 à 10 mille tonnes
d'uranium naturel en moyenne chaque
année nous savons la france a fait le
choix de diversifier ses fournisseurs
d'uranium mais globalement on se
retrouve quand même dépendant de
l'uranium provenant du kazakhstan de
l'australie du niger et de l'ouzbékistan
ces pays sont bien sûr au coeur de
contexte politique et géopolitique très
différents mais j'aurais souhaité savoir
concrètement comment intégrez-vous cette
problématique de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement en uranium dans les
orientations politiques et les
discussions avec les autres états
ensuite pour aborder un sujet plus local
vous avez très certainement de
l'entendre parler du site des bois noirs
dans département de la loire où un
million 1 3 million de tonnes de déchets
radioactifs
sont entreposés en dépit des règles de
stockage en vigueur sous une abdou 2 ha
cette situation d'après mines et de
gestion des déchets dure depuis plus de
40 ans et j'ai eu l'occasion
d'interroger vos prédécesseurs je suis
parlementaire j'ai dû poser des
questions à tous à tous les ministres
concernés à de multiples reprises à ce
sujet et de rencontrer il a 74 aussi
et de rencontrer le cabinet de barbara
pompili au mois de mars dernier lors de
cette rencontre il a été convenu que la
réalisation de l'étude hydrologique du
site ne pouvait plus attendre et que
l'aménagement d'une couverture solide
pour couvrir les déchets semble être la
meilleure solution excusez moi d'être un
peu technique mais plusieurs mois après
nous n'avons aucun retour malgré les
engagements pris dans cette rencontre
ainsi donc madame la ministre
pouvez-vous me faire part de votre
position sur cette problématique locale
et pouvez vous vous engagez pour que ce
sujet qui ne concerne direct qui
concerne directement vos compétences
dans le domaine énergétique soit enfin
traités par les pouvoirs publics merci
madame la ministre merci jean claude
rémy garde ensuite serge mérillou merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
au delà des polémiques liées à la
réouverture annoncée d'une centrale de
charbon ou à l'installation d'un
terminal méthanier pour importer du gaz
de 6
alors que nous avons d'ailleurs interdit
sur notre sol je souhaite vous faire
part de mon incompréhension sur votre
stratégie
depuis le discours du président de la
république ayant adoubé le concept de la
sobriété énergétique pour lequel je suis
totalement favorable
les membres du gouvernement répète à
plusieurs reprises nous devons commencer
par les plus gros apparemment sa figure
dans les eaux des ailes du gouvernement
malheureusement l'exemple systématique
données et l'éclairage qui serait
gaspillée même si nous aurions tort de
ne pas nous priver car c'est simple à
mettre en oeuvre au niveau de la
sobriété et de l'est de l'éclairage ce
n'est pas le plus gros poste de dépense
énergétique et vous le savez très bien
d'ailleurs votre collègue des transports
clément bonnes explique vouloir
solliciter les plus gros opérateurs mais
citent en premier la sncf qui certes est
le plus gros consommateur de france mais
pour l'équipe n'est pas pour l'éclairage
de ces gars mais surtout pour le
transport dois je vous rappeler que le
train consomme 23 fois moins que l'avion
et qu'une telle efficacité il serait
souhaitable que cette consommation
augmente au contraire si nous le si nous
voulons réellement parler de transition
énergétique nous devons évoquer le
résidentiel le tertiaire et avec qui et
le chauffage représente notre plus gros
postes de dépenses que comptez-vous
faire sur ce sujet qui est capital et
pour lequel la politique fixé lors du
grenelle de l'environnement n'a donné
quasiment aucun résultat enfin et pour
vous donner une idée quant au mode de
financement des indispensables isolation
thermique nécessaire pour notre pays je
vous rappelle que les plus gros
pollueurs sont les plus fortunés et que
l'urgence climatique rime avec urgence
énergétique et justice sociale madame la
ministre je suis prêt à construire avec
vous une majorité de projet d'une part
sur un tiers payant rénovation thermique
et d'autre part sur un isf climatique
merci beaucoup
bon faut couvrir
serge mérillou ensuite daniel seulement
madame la ministre mama présidente la
difficulté de passer en dernier ce que
l'essentiel des thèmes ont été abordés
donc je vais essayer
japa dernier mais dans les derniers mois
j'avais j'avais une question posée
concernant la valorisation énergétique
des déchets agricoles donc et d'élevage
notamment par les méthaniseurs ça a été
abordé la même chose sur la forêt avec
la production de ce que nous appelons
les granulés bois bois chauffage ça
aussi ça a été évoqué sur ce point là je
veux quand même mettre en garde sur les
risques de transfert de la production
des méthaniseurs de la production
d'énergie au détriment de la
valorisation de la production de
matières premières agricoles parce que
au prix quelle énergie aujourd'hui
relativement élevés et aux prix des
matières premières agricoles plutôt bas
la tendance pour les agriculteurs à
juste titre et de conforter leurs
revenus en n'utilisant pas seulement des
déchets mais réellement ddd production
agricole donc ça c'est un point sur
lequel je pense qu'on devrait être
sensible un dernier point qui a été
aussi j'veux pas saborder c'est sur la
production d'hydrogène il y a une
volonté je crois du gouvernement
d'apporter
de façon massive 7 milliards d'euros
pour le développement de l'hydrogène
avez vous quelques précisions
complémentaires
et puisqu'on vous a reproché à juste
titre de ne pas avoir une prospective
très très développé les dernières années
moi je vais me projeter très loin est ce
qu on en sait un peu plus sur à échéance
de 30 50 ans sur le projet iter est sûre
et sur la fusion nucléaire qui ici si ce
projet se développe et pourrait être une
des unes des réponses mais non on n'est
pas l'horizon 2035 voilà c'est ce sont
donc c'est un projet il faut bien avoir
des rêves et de l'espérance voilà merci
maman ne peut se permettre serge être
complétés ta question sur iter sur les
conséquences de la guerre russes et des
mauvaises relations avec la russie et
puisqu'ils sont parties prenantes
daniel salmon à qui je ne voudrais pas
voler la question et on finira par
franck montaugé
merci la présidente merci madame la
ministre vous avez évoqué les grands
acteurs qui doivent être exemplaires
pour être exemplaire quelles sont les
procédures que vous allez mettre en
oeuvre en terme de pédagogie et en
termes de contrôle parce qu'on sait que
sans contrôle des fois il n'y a pas
grand-chose qui ce qui se passe du côté
du des panneaux publicitaires lumineux
on sait qu'on est un peu dans le
symbolique en termes de consommation
mais le symbole est souvent important
vous avez décidé de les éteindre de
demander l'extinction la nuit mais je
pense que les heures de pointe sont plus
crucial aujourd'hui et éteindre des
panneaux publicitaires aux heures de
pointe là où beaucoup de gens sont
présents je pense que c'est un signal
important pour la population
autre question l'ouverture des magasins
le dimanche est-ce que et bien en plein
hiver il est judicieux d'ouvrir des
grandes surfaces le dimanche voilà ce
n'est que ce n'est qu'une simple
question
vous a évoqué également les contrats les
contrats
les abonnements qui sont favorables à la
à la sobriété comme les contrats
anciennement appelée ejp aujourd'hui il
ya les tempos je pense effectivement que
ce sont des contrats très très
intéressant et important pour prendre
conscience de la consommation mais aussi
pour écrêter sur les heures de pointe
donc je pense que il va falloir les
relances et je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous sur ce sur ce sujet vous avez
évoqué le photovoltaïque et les panneaux
souvent construits en chine c'est une
réalité j'ai appris hier que total
energy fermait sa dernière usine de
production de panneaux photovoltaïques
en france comment pensez-vous relancer
notre filière nationale à ce sujet un
sujet qui a déjà été abordé par nos
collègues à l'instant la biomasse donc
on va assister effectivement à une ruée
sur la biomasse avec de nombreux usages
on a face à cela de nombreux aléas
climatiques
avez vous mis en place une véritable
planification avec une hiérarchisation
des usages entre l'alimentation humaine
alimentation animale fibres et énergie
je pense qu'il faut vraiment avancer à
la fois vite mais aussi prudemment sur
le sujet pour ne pas être demain
confrontés à des à des grosses
difficultés
je ne viendrai pas durablement sur le
nucléaire
effectivement je dois être faire partie
de la jeunesse donc parce que j'ai un
avis un peu différenciés par rapport à
de nombreuses personnes ici
je pense que un débat national serait
bienvenue qu'envisagez vous sur ce débat
pour que les français un jour se
prononce sur cette énergie qui nous
engage non pas sur une deux générations
mais sur 50 génération il serait quand
même un petit peu dommage que comme
beaucoup se réveille sur le
réchauffement climatique au moment où la
france brûlé où il ya des sécheresses on
se réveille demain au lendemain d'un
accident nucléaire
merci daniel on peut te reconnaître une
forme de constance
ces sujets là et pour le clou du
spectacle franck montaugé
merci merci madame la présidente
en espérant que le sujet n'ait pas été
déjà abordé excusez moi pour mon absence
dans le cadre de la stratégie nationale
bas carbone de la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie a fortiori
que l'on va réviser dans quelques temps
comment
anticipez-vous la question de la
planification ou de la programme
programmation des différents moyens de
production sur le territoire national il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas dans cette
question évidemment que le nucléaire est
loin s'en faut il ya la question des
énergies renouvelables dans toutes leurs
leur variété voilà quelques elle quel
processus envisagez vous pour que les
choses se passent au mieux qu on n'y
passe pas trop de temps compte tenu des
urgences
au niveau de l'étang au niveau des
régions la loi alors je crois que
c'était climat énergie a introduit la
notion de comité régional de l'énergie
dans les départements il ya des
syndicats départementaux d'énergie il ya
des collectivités locales il ya des
préfets à la tout ça mérite je pense
d'être activée dans le bon sens comment
voyez vous les choses et dernière
question pour la route comme on dit chez
moi un peu provocatrice et peut-être
peut-être pas faux nez mais je tente
quand même au regard des problèmes
techniques constatées sur le nucléaire
de première génération avez vous estimez
vous avez vous une estimation de la
faisabilité du programme grand carénage
et surtout de ses effets
parce qu'on pourrait se trouver dans une
situation où effectivement on engage des
investissements pour prolonger la durée
de vie des réacteurs et on se retrouve
confronté à nouveau à des problèmes
techniques évidemment pas ce que je
souhaite ce qu'on souhaite ici mais
c'est pas exclue est ce que cette
question-là extrêmement complexe et j'en
ai conscience vous l'avez vous l'avez
prise en compte d'une manière ou d'une
autre pour faire une sorte que voilà on
est quand même un parc de production qui
répond à
la consommation appelées merci merci
voilà madame la ministre pour
planification
perspective c'est parti alors monsieur
le sénateur cabanel
en fait la maintenance programmée elle
est parfaitement pilotable elle et
anticipable puisque ne serait-ce que les
arrêts pour rechargement du nucléaire
c'est la gestion courante des réacteurs
et je précise une chose la maintenance
elle a été positionné l'été parce qu'on
a moins besoin d'électricité l'été ça ne
vous aura pas échappé et c'est donc la
résultante d'un exercice de
programmation qui fait qu' on fait en
sorte et vous le verrez sur les mythes
puisque il y à une transparence totale
sur les arrêts programmés des centrales
nucléaires avec les dates de démarrage
et les dates de la datar et l'état de
redémarrage et vous avez également un
scénario qui intègre des aléas que l'on
peut rencontrer sur ce type sur ce type
d'art et donc de ce point de vue là le
la situation des 30 réacteurs arrêtés
c'est la résultante vous avez 12
réacteurs pour lequel pour le coup une
situation corrosion sous contrainte qui
n'a pas été rencontrés dans d'autres
sites mais qui est peut-être aussi la
résultante du niveau accru de contrôle
qui sont faits dans le cadre du post
fukushima et de la qualité des travaux
de l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire et des
équipes d'un d'edf en règle générale il
faut aussi regarder cet aspect là le
deuxième sujet c'est pour les 18 autres
c'est soit la résultante mécanique du
rechargement du nucléaire soit la
résultante mécanique de passage de
visites décennales ou de
d'anticipation de grand carénage soit
effectivement un calendrier qui était un
peu plus bousculé du fait de la co vide
et tout ça est assez facilement est
assez facilement document table là où on
a des marges de progrès c'est le fait
que les arrêts
soit donc dans les temps on va dire
optimisée du rhin sont prévues soient
respectés c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
dérapage sur la durée des arrêts et vous
savez que ma prédécesseure a demandé un
rapport aux équipes d'edf sur ce
sujet-là qui l'a terminée qui formule
des recommandations
faki là qui a été d'ailleurs mené par
des parties externes certaines
spécialiste du nucléaire d'autres
spécialistes de l'industrie d'autres
spécialistes de l'ingénierie pour avoir
une vision à 360 degrés avec des
recommandations sur comment
systématiser ces exercices de
maintenance des centrales et faire en
sorte que lorsqu'on annonce 60 jours en
face 60 jours et pas 70 jours parce que
c'est un élément qui effectivement dit
mentionnant sur notre reproductibles et
qu'il sera de plus en plus au fur et à
mesure on en a des arts est un peu lourd
à exécuter sur sur monsieur tissot sur
l'approvisionnement en uranium et les
questions de sécurité je vais faire une
réponse très comment en pointillés
puisque ce sont des sujets qui sont
considérés comme extraordinairement
confidentiel pour vous dire que nous
avons des stocks pour vous dire
également que là pour vous rassurer mais
faudra me croire sur parole pour vous
dire également que sur
l'approvisionnement c'est plutôt les
pays de l'est de l'europe qui ont besoin
de la russie pour les approvisionnements
en uranium et pour vous dire enfin qu'en
tout état de cause d une réflexion
évidemment sur la diversification de
l'approvisionnement avec les états unis
le royaume uni et cora noah un projet
d'extension de capacité
qui pourraient être déployés si elle
sécurise aussi il sécurisé des contrats
à long terme nous avons nous mêmes une
capacité d'intégration verticale qui est
un élément s'agissant la filière
française de réassurance s'agissant la
filière européenne de soutien potentiel
sur les bois noir je comprends que
madame la préfète travail avec aura nos
pour obtenir les études nécessaires et
c'est suivi de très près par la
direction générale de la prévention des
risques
ce stade je ne peux pas vous en dire
plus monsieur car non sur les questions
de charbon et de gaz de schiste
je vais pas refaire le débat qui a eu
lieu à l'assemblée nationale j'aimerais
qu'on sorte
de la tribune foraines ont fait des
raccourcis un peu rapide je le redis la
trajectoire de baisse de nos émissions
carbone n'est pas remise en question
la centrale de saint-avold qui va être
attelé l'hiver prochain n'a pas vocation
à émettre plus que l'année dernière et
je rappelle que la production de charbon
c'est 1% 1 % de notre mix électricité je
rappelle qu'en allemagne c'est 26 %
avant le redémarrage un certain nombre
de centrales à charbon dans les
circonstances que nous connaissons
toutes les émissions de co2 seront
compensées elles seront compensées par
des projets concrets et jeux de mémoire
je sais pas si c'est vous si c'est
l'assemblée nationale enfin certains
élus ont souhaité que cette compensation
se fasse en france ce qui me paraît
acceptable
donc nous sommes et puis s'agissant
du gaz pardon mais personne n'a songé
ces 15 dernières années et je me semble
me rappeler qu'il ya eu plusieurs
groupes politiques qui se sont succédé à
la tête de ce pays à interdire les
importations de gaz de schiste or la
fracturation hydraulique est une
technologie qui n'est pas exploité par
les états unis et qui est aujourd'hui
quasiment employés dans tous les
gisements
onshore
ça n'a posé problème à personne donc ce
alors que c'est en 2011 que la france
sous un gouvernement d'ailleurs
républicain et pas de gauche a arrêté
a interdit l'utilisation enfin
d'utiliser cette technologie en france
voilà donc pourquoi pourquoi ça a tout
simplement parce qu'on sait pas bien
faire la différence entre une molécule
de gaz naturel qui aurait été obtenue
par fracturation hydraulique une
molécule de gaz naturel qui n'auraient
pas été obtenues par fracturation
hydraulique et qu'on va pas des fléchés
et que donc en réalité si vous voulez
vraiment avoir accès au gaz naturel eh
bien il ya ce que vous faites sur votre
territoire et nous avons pris nos
responsabilités et c'est ni ni vous ni
vous mais il ya une grosse dizaine
d'années que ça c'est fait et
collectivement et ses portes et ça a été
assumée par les mandatures suivante qui
n'ont pas remis en question cette
décision
mais aujourd'hui
je trouve en fait assez démagogique de
porter le débat sur ce sujet là pour le
dire très clairement ce d'autant qu'on
remplace des gaz naturel par du gaz
naturel et que la russie utilise aussi
la fracturation hydraulique
voilà sur la question de la sobriété je
ne sais pas où vous avez lu que notre
enjeu c'est l'éclairage je sais pas vous
l'avez lu
ah non je je alors peut-être que les
revues de presse sont l'alpha et l'oméga
de notre politique énergétique moi je
vous renvoie vers les communiqués de
presse qui reprennent en fait tous les
secteurs du jeu les transports les
déplacements travail salarié domicile
travail et au sein des entreprises est
de même pour
là l'état je revends je vous renvoie la
circulaire de la première ministre qui
évoque plutôt le chauffage et la
climatisation que l'éclairage même si
évidemment doit évoquer cette situation
puisque nous cherchons toutes les
sources d'électricité
je rappelle aussi que pour les
collectivités locales des communes
l'éclairage ses 37 % de leurs dépenses
de facture énergétique 37% donc en fait
ça dépend à quel acteur vous vous
adressez à quel acteur vous adresser
dans les ménages le sujet va plutôt se
porter sur le chauffage dans les
entreprises ça dépendra en fait de
l'organisation de l'entreprise et de son
positionnement est ce que c'est des
bureaux est ce que c'est un site
industriel est ce que ce sont des
activités de services qui suppose des
déplacements et c'est pour ça que nous
avons cette approche qui est une
approche différenciée par type d'acteur
vous m'interrogez sur le résidentiel et
le tertiaire je viens de dire que nous
avons lancé un groupe sur le logement
est un groupe sur le tertiaire et que
sur le tertiaire toute une série de
mesures ont été prises qui porte sur la
climatisation sur le chauffage sur
l'éclairage sur le niveau sonore des
magasins sur
également les les zones de froid donc il
est assez large et qui est relayée non
seulement par perifem qui est plutôt la
grande distribution mais également par
la fcd et maintenant par des
associations de commerçants de deux qui
sont plus on va dire de taille plus plus
petit donc de petits commerçants donc le
sujet effectivement pleinement pris en
main et je veux les remercier ici parce
que
la réalité c'est que ça aurait été les
premiers à sortir avec des propositions
très claires au delà de l'état qui peut
plus facilement promener décisions
directement sur le tiers payant de la
rénovation thermique je partage votre
avis je pense que c'est une démarche
très intéressante la question qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est
sur quel objet ils sont positionnés
puisqu'il faut avoir les objets des plus
standard possible pour pouvoir porter
cette cette approche mais je crois
savoir qu'ils y compris en logements
résidentiels il y a des précédents qui
fonctionne donc c'est un point où je
suis ravi de travailler sur les sf
climatique sans surprise je vous dirais
que le pays qui taxe le plus les
entreprises d'europe n'est pas forcément
le mieux positionné pour un rajouter sur
le sujet donc voilà je j'entends que
certains pays taxent ont des projets de
taxation je pense que joue raison notre
niveau de taxation des entreprises
peut-être qu'il ne songeront pas à
mettre en place des mesures
additionnelles a fortiori lorsque ces
projets sont assortis crédit d'impôt
pour le développement de projets dans
l'énergie qui pesé l'énergie fossile est
quand même assez étonnant sur monsieur
mérillon luz alors vous vous posez la
question des conflits d'usagé
qui est une excellente question et sur
lequel nous avons effectivement alors
sur le sur la partie biogaz un décret
qui précise des limitations pour
évidemment ne pas avoir un effet d'exit
sur les la biomasse et les productions
alimentaires
avec aussi des souplesses parce qu'on
nous dit mais il suffit qu'il ya un
épisode de gel penseront trop qu'on
retrouve de la biomasse inexploitable en
alimentation mais qui peut utilement
aller dans un méthaniseur donc voilà il
faut tenir compte de ces réalités le
décret moi je pensais l'avoir signé donc
n'est pas encore sorti bon ok
ça va venir
ok sur la question de l'hydrogène ses
8,9 milliards d'euros si on cumule le
premier set mignard et les deux
milliards par hier vers 9 milliards
additionnels du projet france 2030 c'est
à la fois sur les usages c'est à dire
comment décarbonés les grandes
plateformes industrielles et notamment
dunkerque e
fos-sur-mer enfin les savait qu'il ya
cinq plateformes les plus émettrices en
france qui font 30 % des émissions de
co2 et vous avez sur le volet solution
offre de solutions et là nous sommes une
soutenons un certain nombre de projets
pile à combustible de stockage pour
avoir la filière équipements et c'est au
fond la réponse à ce qu'on a vécu sur le
photovoltaïque c'est de commencer par
mettre en place des filières avant que
de vouloir équiper à marche forcée des
territoires avec des solutions qui sont
pas nécessairement un contenu aux
européens ou aux françaises
sur épis y ait aussi des projets à
destination des territoires ça c'est
important parce que ça peut créer de
même que les réseaux de chaleur c'est un
peu la même dynamique et je pense que
c'est vraiment l'avenir cette réflexion
l'énergie au niveau territorial donc
tout cook
sur iter et la fusion nucléaire je vous
rejoins il faut d'abord avoir des rêves
et puis si effectivement il était
réalisé ce serait
serait de nature à transformer notre
notre programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie très certainement inversement
si on est capable de faire du stockage
à haute densité d'énergie renouvelable
c'est la même chose r vous craquez le
sujet des énergies renouvelables et de
l'intermittence donc nous l' approche
qu'on a c'est une approche de neutralité
technologique où on essaye de pousser
sur les différentes options qui se
présentent à nous on essaye aussi de ne
pas se concentrer que sur l'électricité
je veux parler la géothermie par contre
par exemple je pense que c'est un sujet
qui est très porteur et qu'il faut
expérimenter sur lequel on a des acteurs
qui peuvent se positionner en france en
plus d'un point de vue industriel donc
ça vaut vraiment le coup d'être regardé
il faut regarder la chaleur renouvelable
parce qu'au-delà de la biomasse donc
voilà il ya il ya d'autres projets mais
vous avez raison il faut ouvrir les
choses et être capable de pivoter sur
notre programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie peut-être que nos successeurs
ou vous pour les plus jeunes d'entre
vous qui seront là dans quelques années
on aura une vision différente de notre
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
et c'est cet ajustement permanent qu'il
faut être capable de faire sur sur les
panneaux lumineux le jour vous le dit
vous êtes un petit peu provocateur je
pense que en mesure de routine plutôt
pas plus qu'en plus nous avons cette
faculté à avoir une électricité qui
savait que l'électricité n'est pas
stockham donc si on a de l'électricité
notamment d'origine éolienne et qu'on
peut produire
on n'est pas obligé non plus de disrupt
et toutes les toutes les chaînes de
production et les chaîne de création de
valeur est ce que dans un contexte de
tension ça peut être des réflexions de
se dire qu'est ce qu'on retire moi j'ai
entendu un patron
de grands magasins expliqué qu'il ne
s'interdirait pas de fermer des magasins
en situation de tension
mais voilà mais messi c'est sa démarche
à lui voilà
nous l'accueillons contrat heures
pleines heures creuses oui évidemment
c'est
c'est un sujet sur lequel travaille nos
énergéticiens j'attends leur retour
j'aurais écrit a tous le 7 juillet
dernier je crois que pour le moment
c'est edf qui nous a répondu mais je
pense que d'autres réponses devraient
suivre sur le photovoltaïque comment
relancer la filière industrielle il ya
plusieurs enjeux il ya l'enjeu de
compétitivité de notre industrie la
baisse des impôts de production le fait
d'avoir un territoire plus attractif de
monter plus vite des chaînes de
production on a des acteurs français
mais qui sont pas encore complètement
bien positionné vous savez qu'on avait
regardé aussi une manière assez profonde
et un projet rexall art on a un projet
first solar donc on discute aussi avec
un certain nombre d'acteurs étrangers
qui possède là
[Musique]
la technologie avec la volonté de
remonter le plus haut sur le plus
rapide en stream pardon le plus loin en
amont sur la chaîne de valeur pour ne
pas être juste en assemblage de cellules
photovoltaïques sont pas forcément très
porteur mais vraiment d'intégrer toute
la technologie
pour ça il faut probablement aussi un
volet normatif réglementaire en mode de
ce qu'on est en train de finaliser sur
le règlement batterie électrique c'est à
dire de positionner au niveau européen
une vision de ce qui doit être produits
avec un niveau
environnemental qui soif élevé de façon
à ce que ce ne soit pas une mesure de
protectionnisme un peu crasse mais
plutôt une maintenant parce que ça peut
être la tentation et c'est pas forcément
servir le consommateur mais qui soit une
mesure qui tienne compte de la réalité
davantage compétitifs en matière
environnementale ou de la réalité d'un
mix énergétique qui est décarbonée et ça
ce sont des éléments qui nous sont
notamment comptes communiqués par les
porteurs de projets de dire de fixer des
niveaux d'émissions de co2 assorti à une
production des niveaux maximum
c'est une façon d'entraîner finalement
une toute la filière et de lui donner un
avantage compétitif ou de reconnaître
son avantage compétitif
sur la biomasse à la hiérarchisation des
usages je vous renvoie effectivement la
même question c'est à dire qu'on a ce
décret qui dit pas plus de 15%
de dieu biomasse d'origine
enfin le terme à la culture voilà et
puis
le fait qu'on a aussi une
hiérarchisation niveau européenne sur
les mêmes sujets
débat sur le nucléaire
je sais plus quelle était la question
est-ce qu'il faut un débat oui si c'est
la stratégie c'est la stratégie
française énergie climat alors ce débat
va avoir lieu il va avoir lieu dans deux
moments c'est dans la stratégie
française énergie climat vous avez un
débat public qui pose notamment la
question du mix énergétique et qui donc
va notamment posé la question du
nucléaire et qui va permettre
d'introduire le débat des deux réacteur
de penly qui suivent dans la foulée
c'était leur première question c'est
pourquoi d'une femme qu'elle mixe
énergétique et
derrière chaque élément énergétique
qu'elles sont qu'est ce qui ressort du
débat public comme élément de à prendre
en compte et là encore je veux ouvrir
sur l'ensemble du spectre énergétique
parce que on ne parle que du nucléaire
et des énergies renouvelables on oublie
juste que nous sommes encore
extraordinairement dépendant des
énergies fossiles certes pour se
transporter pour se chauffer enfin c'est
quand même le gros c'est le gros du
problème et c'est vrai que notre prisme
électricité nous détournent parfois du
gros sujet de l'éléphant qui est dans la
pièce est donc effectivement à cette
occasion là le sujet du nucléaire est
abordé à la fois dans sa dimension dans
le
la party mix mais également dans la
partie gestion de l'après nucléaire d
mentalement déchets et s'est cassé notre
intention dans le cadre du dialogue
public et en terme de et d'ailleurs je
pense est important que vous y soyez
associés ont gelé dit j'ai dit à la cndp
aussi et en termes de calendrier
si on arrive à tenir c'est fin septembre
lancement du débat public
général sur la stratégie énergie climat
début octobre mi octobre le débat
particulier sur les deux perles et de
réacteur de penly
fin d'année on ferme la partie qui
s'appelle maxi public et on ouvre la
partie mini public avec notamment
des groupes autour des 18 25 ans puisque
c'est quand même eux qui vont quelque
part être impactés par ces décisions que
nous prenons aujourd'hui sont plus les
plus concernés en termes générationnel
fermeture ensuite de ce débat en janvier
et travaille sur la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie et la loi
énergie climat que nous devons vous
présenter je pense qu'on vous la
présentera plus tôt en deuxième partie
d'année 2023 pour que les choses soient
bien faites je vous redis moment
mon ambition
mon objectif j'espère atteignable c'est
d'avoir une ppe qui boucle et d'avoir
une tpe qui soient fondées sur des faits
et des réalités et la science sont deux
objets un peu important je pense
nécessaire si on veut bien porter le
débat
monsieur moto j'ai
alors planification la programmation d
énergie j'ai anticipé la réponse à la
question
oui on va y pour se passer du temps je
pense que c'est nécessaire d'y passer du
temps je le dis sous le contrôle de deux
équipes qui ont beaucoup de travail en
ce moment mais je pense que c'est
nécessaire parce qu'on voit bien que ce
qui a été fait sur par rte sur les
scénarios de production d'électricité a
été extraordinairement aidant on a pris
deux ans alors là on vous dit pas qu'on
va prendre deux ans mais on a pris deux
ans ils ont travaillé avec 4000 experts
ils ont 40 personnes qui ont porté le
projet de rapport ils ont tracé six
scénarios ils ont étudié tous les
scénarios et finalement on travaille sur
des éléments qui sont très structurant
et qui ont permis de dépasser des débats
qui était un peu
caricaturaux et on est rentré je pense
vraiment dans un niveau d'appropriation
de ces sujets énergétiques on a passé un
cap et mon ambition c'est qu'on essaye
d'avoir un peu la même chose mais sur
des sujets un peu plus large sachant
qu'en parallèle
christophe béchu doit travailler sur la
mise à jour de sa stratégie nationale
bas carbone et que tout ça doit prendre
en compte le paquet climat de l'union
européenne et pour être rentré un peu
dans le détail des textes et les avoir
portées en tant que présidence française
alors après barbara peau claire qui a
fait 5 mois de travail ne fait pas payer
des fleurs à titre personnel derniers
mois j'ai pu rentrer dans le détail de
ces textes sont des textes
extraordinairement dimensionnant
extraordinairement dimensionnant et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui ni la
représentation nationale ni les
entreprises ni les français n'en ont
pris la mesure je pense à l'efficacité
énergétique je pense à l'augmentation
des enjeux sur le renouvelable même le
règlement le lui cf et donc est donc
derrière il ya vraiment cette
appropriation affaires et d'ailleurs
c'est un très bel objet pardon en
profite c'est un très bel objet de
rapports alors c'est pas un objet d'un
seul rapport c'est un très bel objet de
beaucoup de rapports parce que vous avez
sept textes
wet non je vous parle de du paquet
climat européen c'est-à-dire le paquet
climat européen
décide dessine une des éléments de
planification qui seront dimensionnant
pour notre propre planification c'est ça
que je veux partager avec vous et que
nous avons porté un
l'appropriation des textes pour
permettre la planification en 16 et sur
toutes les trajets un
nom parce que on vous
alors je vous sur
l'un n'empêche pas l'autre l'un
n'empêche pas l'autre c'est-à-dire
typiquement le raccordement
le raccordement des énergies
renouvelables c'est un sujet que nous on
aborde là dans notre plan d'urgence
parce qu'on a un certain nombre de
d'installation renouvelables qui ne sont
pas raccordés ce qui est un problème est
par ailleurs ça invite dans la
planification a peut-être se poser la
question à l'envers d'ailleurs certaines
entreprises l'ont bien compris en
développement c'est plutôt que de poser
son site et d'attendre d'être accordés
est de dire mais quand même scrogneugneu
c'est invraisemblable je serai raccordés
dans x temps il faut peut-être se poser
la question de coût sont les points de
raccordement et je pose mon projet aux
nerfs à proximité de ce projet de
raccordement
mais ça va le faire en temps masqué
non mais je dis monsieur le sénateur je
vous le dis très clairement vous me
parlez planification énergétique
planification énergétique c'est à 20 ans
ok raccordement on est en train de le
faire là maintenant
la programmation elle et à la
planification aller en 2050 avec un
arrêt en 2030 la programmation m et 1 5
ans et les sujets de raccordement 6
contre est là en ce moment pour
accélérer notre résilience énergétique
très bien merci écoutez d'abord de l'âme
la ministe voudrais vous remercier parce
que 2h30 d'audition c'est assez rare
qu'un ministre prenne la peine de rester
aussi longtemps avec nous donc merci
beaucoup pardon francs
à grande car y avait une
question vous avez raison
problème technique sur le nucléaire
faisabilité du programme grand carénage
eux oui alors moi je vais vous je vais
vous répondre en disant oui c'est
faisable il ya des conditions de succès
les conditions de succès elles sont
notamment sur les compétences et elles
sont et c'est un sujet qui fait partie
des clairement des priorités majeures du
futur dirigeant et de l'équipe
dirigeante d'edf c'est à dire que je
crois que l'attendu de la part du
gouvernement sur edf
c'est d'avoir comme
priorité absolue
un projet industriel et d'excellence
opérationnelle
avant tout avec l'existant
l'optimisation de l'existant le
nucléaire mais également hydroélectrique
avec ensuite des sujets du grand
carénage qui est un projet qui ce prêt
qui se prépare maintenant pour être
capables de passer les jalons à venir et
qui se prépare avec l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire est mentionné notamment la
question des moyens de l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire et peut-être aussi de
l'équipement avec des éléments de
nouvelles technologies qui pourraient
les aider et le troisième élément c'est
le programme nouveau nucléaire
effectivement quand on factories ça en
terme de nombre de ressources à mettre
en place et de pilotage d'entreprise
c'est un sujet qui exige d'avoir des
personnes extraordinaires solide et pas
seulement une personne mais une équipe
extraordinairement solide avec des
comment dire des feuilles de route très
claires et des objectifs très clairs et
à
face en miroir une délégation
interministérielle
sur le nouveau leclerc et puis nous on
appuie sur les autres sujets puisque les
administrations qui soit également gré
pour répondre à ces gens je vais oui
vous avez raison c'est possible on a les
compétences mais il faut vraiment les à
botter et avoir un suivi au plus près de
ses sujets voilà merci donc je
renouvelle même la ministre rien ne vous
avez nous a été épargné donc
merci beaucoup du temps que vous avez
consacré vous même et votre équipe nous
aurons l'occasion de de partager encore
quelques moments dans les jours qui
viennent en tout cas merci pour la
qualité du temps que vous nous avez
consacré jo j'ai entendu madame la
ministre que la pp serait plutôt pour le
deuxième semestre de l'année 2023 si ça
pouvait ne pas être en juillet ça serait
vraiment
vraiment voilà parce que ça coince en
fait voilà parce que on a souvenir de la
loi énergie il ya deux ou trois ans
qu'il a fallu faire en urgence avant la
fin de séance vraiment dans des
conditions là aussi qui était limite
mais enfin bon voilà donc prenons le
temps c'est très important et je pense
que passer le 14 juillet on fait des
bêtises bon voilà donc merci beaucoup je
profite juste de la fin de séance se
méfie recoller pour vous proposer que
patrick chauvet sur notre rapporteur
pour l'audition de madame wargon qui est
proposée par le président de la
république au poste de présidente de la
cre eux ce qui est des objections à ce
que ce soit patrick ce nom